[Music]
nah
n
[Music]
nah
n
[Music]
yeah yeah
yeah Vol call what's going on around how
we doing out here on the Sunday Sunday
Sunday what we doing make sure to levels
is right getting it off
right see y'all in there early salute
salute me a second to get my situation
together here we go what's going on real
how we doing Mike checks what's going on
audio's good tank 89 welcome to Lord
silver silver Lords in the building
reing I see Lord gamesley up in there
early you know what I'm saying
representing Big Bill what's going on
young dreads OG what's up young OG
what's going on lyia Master what's up
Barry the zelan I think that's how you
pronounce it what's going on Matthew ask
John Wolf what's up John Wolf what's
going on Gerald Matthew OG oh hell the
IR salute salute you already know
hindsight with the hustle what's going
on brother hope hope everyone is well
know D salute salute popn with the beat
drop what's going on what's going going
on we got a lot in here already no doubt
salute salute Parker buris all right
yeah yeah that beat go hard it
definitely
do neax what's up what's going on Bo the
clown David Talbert what's going on
Commander Romus Dy passion official I
see you the hooded can what's up Edward
Walt what's going on Black Lightning all
right all right 8's cartoon
villain no doubt no doubt he hope
everything's going well yeah Sunday you
know we're trying to get it together a
lot of people traveling families you
know what I mean so we got to see how
this going to go today because um
everybody's got a lot going on right now
I know s's got a lot going on Kings got
got a lot going on it's holiday time
plus we winding down towards the end of
the year long year but good one for the
most part and uh yeah we're trying to
get these final think two iops out then
we probably need a break we got to
recharge you know what I'm saying messed
up to hit that 2024 extra strong but
yeah we'll let y'all know when we do
that but it's good to see y'all up in
here early David Callin what's up whoop
whoop
kid oh Ed salute welcome to the bronze
yes yes love to see it love to see it so
yo oh going on Pyon Fusion so we going
to get adct coming in we going to see
what's going on with him we going see
what's going on I spoke to King earlier
this sa might might join us in progress
cuz he he's moving around moving and
shaking with the family but anyway we
going to see y'all up in here uh we're
going to react to the game awards live
yes at minimum me and addict I think
King should be but um yeah yeah we will
do a live reaction to that plus that's
what today's about we got a I got to Def
defeat s all of us we have to defeat s
his picks are always good so we're going
to go through the categories we're going
to do Crown your L try to do it today if
possible if s could make it get his pcks
in and then when we do the live show we
do the tally up and see who actually
predicts all the nominees correctly who
has the most this is something that s
has dominated every year since we've
done this thing I think it's about 5
years now it's been ADM minute geek the
sneak what's going on M for one more
salute no doubt so look let me go get
the rest of the Lords make sure
everybody's good and I'll see you in a
minute here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lord's podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y'all to messed up and turn me
to an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and makeing inflammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Saron up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I be running
collecting the range you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
of started regardless back when you was
messaging people on a check mycs Twitter
but I'm anal love my city but I'm still
Co I
got stop that was dope keep that keep
that keep that going keep that going n
Go ahead look I guess you can say that
I'm very spoil to be your dog they very
loyal but I ain't going to hold you I
ain't here the boy you you ain't got to
say it I'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
vult Tron with a gang of cougars and I'm
going places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y to messed up and turn me to an
animal and heades be swearing they real
but come to find out that they real
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a canable and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
the song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's arson up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting and range you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when was
messaging people on a check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm antisocial love
my city but I'm still by coal I got
let's you don't stop that was dope keep
that keep that keep that going keep that
going n Go ahead look I guess you could
say that I'm very spoil feel to be your
dog they very loyal but I ain't going to
hold you I ain't heard the boy you ain't
got to say it I'm embarrassed for you
always been a nerd never been a loser
making Vault try with a gang of cougar
and I'm going places better tell a uber
cuz it's pretty hard to sleep on Freddy
kruer that's
let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am U
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y'all messed up in turn to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's sing up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I be running collecting the
range you just a Target when I'm in the
range I was the hardest of started
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm antisocial love my city
but I'm still by coal I got let's
Swit
you thatp keep that keep that going keep
that going no go ahead look I guess you
can say that I'm very SPO to be your dog
thing very loyal but I ain't going to
hold you I ain't heard the boy you ain't
got to say it I'm embarrassed for you
always been a nerd never been a loser
making Vault Tron with a gang of cougars
and I'm going places better till a
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we about to get started I am well
it's not important who I am um what's
important is that you are pulling up to
the iron Lords podcast right now as we
speak and uh I guess I'm here to keep
you entertained until it's time to get
this show started so um
look y to messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the Snapple and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
that they it's arson up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the range you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on a check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm antisocial love my city
but I'm still by coal I got let's Swit
what you do don't stop that was dope
keep that keep that going keep that
going n Go ahead look I guess you could
say that I'm very spoiled feel to be
your dog thing very loyal but I ain't
going to hold you I ain't heard the bo
you you ain't got to say it I'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making Vault Tron
with a gang of cougars and I'm going
places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and head is be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be hanni they
be like why use a video game just be
original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is y this is that Yoga Fire Flame they
they can s up in the apartment they call
a department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting them R you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start regardless back
when you was messaging people on AIM
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
antisocial love my city but I'm still
byal I
got's what you do stop that wasp keep
that keep that going keep that going go
ahead look I guess you could say that
I'm very spoal feeling to be your dog
thing very loyal but I ain't going to
hold you I ain't heard boy you ain't got
to say it I'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
Vault Tron with a gang of cougars and
I'm going places better tell a uber cuz
it's pretty hard to sleep I'm fry kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lord's podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y'all to messed up and turn me
to an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a accountable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
Bea and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I was
random but I am addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable this is
that this is that Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's sing up in the apartment they
call the department and I get the blame
still I'll be running collecting and
range you just a Target when I'm in the
range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm antisocial love my city
but I'm still coal I
got's Don't Stop N that was dope keep
that keep that keep that going keep that
going n Go ahead look I guess you can
say that I'm very spoil to be your dog
thing very loyal but I ain't going to
hold you I ain't heard the boy you ain't
got to say it I'm embarrassed for you
always been a nerd never been a loser
making Vault Tron with a ganger cougar
and I'm going places better tell a uber
cuz it's pretty hard to sleep on Freddy
kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important that you are pulling up
to the iron Lords podcast right now as
we speak and uh I guess I'm here to keep
you entertained until it's time to get
this show started so
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and head is be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a accountable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be hanal they
be like why use a video game just be
original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Saron up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the range you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back we was
messaging people on a check my vocals I
on Twitter but I'm antisocial love my
city but I'm still by coal I got's Swit
what you do don't stop that waspe keep
that keep get that going go ahead look I
guess you could say that I'm very spoil
feel them to be your dog they very loyal
but I ain't going to hold you I ain't
heard the boy you ain't got to say it
I'm embarrassed for you always been a
nerd never been a loser making Vault
Tron with a gang of cougars and I'm
going places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am U
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y'all messed up and turn me to
an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's sing up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
and range you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm antisocial love my city
but I'm still by coal I got let's switch
that up
don't stop that was dope keep keep that
keep that going keep that going n Go
ahead look I guess you can say that I'm
very spoiled feeling to be your dog
thing very loyal but I ain't going to
hold you I ain't heard the bo you you
ain't got to say it I'm embarrassed for
you always been a nerd never been a
loser making vultron with a gang of
cougars and I'm going places better tell
a uber cuz it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do that good
stuff that we need to do and um you know
we're about to get started I am well
it's not important who I am um what's
important is that you are pulling up to
the iron Lords podcast right now as we
speak and uh I guess I'm here to keep
you entertained until it's time to get
this show started so
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and head be
[Music]
swearing prior call Proclaim all cloud
and clear a proclamation of invitation
turn not on
me I C
the the
[Music]
river I'mma just chill and watch them
snacks in the attic I wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young whoop
but then they will mistake me for atct
if I can imagine it's cool to get you
some advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cuz if you don't give her that
option you going to be single player
like Sovereign you going to get tossed
in the bushes by King David Royal and
not a pretender detrimental to a
Elemental what's a avatar to a knee
Bender I got to be NE I know it's my
destiny work to kindo who cares if you
fly if you still a mosquito you swear
you ain't something but really be steo
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but I got bad news even if you
really was that dud King still be the
king of the statue since a juvenal I've
been cursed with a curse to be Musical
and if you you hated will meet in The
Crucible other than that it's cool and
it's beautiful we let you know that your
dreams are pursuable whatever you want
to do then it's doable if you got work
on a Sunday it's suitable cuz you can
listen to this in your cubicle on the
Lord's
day if you got work on a Sunday a
suitable cuz you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the Lord's
[Music]
Day
EXC attic dancing like last night yeah I
heard you you you the man with the one
two with the
moves yeah what's funny is after after
it happened Alex like you know you gonna
hear about that oh yeah we we heard it
we saw the moment the moment in the down
I knew that that was getting that that
was getting clipped oh man Street on you
baby streets is on the mic checks is
good look like everybody coming through
good here ye here ye and we are live
welcome welcome to the iron Lords
podcast LLC and also live on Lords of
gaming.net episode number 332 they said
addicts dancing was
fire dance dance dance yo they got dance
dancing yo they crazy anyway it's
another glorious Sunday we're back at
the round table of the Lord's day yes we
will talk about s Doctor Strange Love
relax Jesus s where's my boo boo what's
going
on and today we got should Xbox save the
cotour Remake embracer layoffs
PlayStation store
lawsuit I know whose topic that is and
Xbox Presence at the game of on to
discuss so we going to get right into it
so let's introduce uh oh one's missing
one's missing where he at don't you
don't you love how when Cog says that he
acts like he just noticed just found
down I don't know what's going on I
don't know what's going on where is he
one of these kids is doing his own
shout up send your love to
S he should be joining in progress he
should be joy to get a lot of possibly
could be what saying s send your love to
S he's not hurt he's not injured there's
no family stuff going on he just had
stuff that happened I just saying
there's a lot of people crying out in
the chat where is their beloved s you
know I just want to make sure I want to
quell the bastes let know he should be
you know coming through still I got to
deal with this this [__] the rest of the
year now language adct do the do the
Truffle Shuffle I don't even know what
that
is anyway so but we still got the other
Lords in the realm my co-host the Coos
my brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror Lord of his own
world and the how of the young wolf my
man Lord adct back to back with the
dance moves and everything what's going
on oh my God we are not putting that in
my intro yes with the dance moves
pretty good I I I jump back into uh you
know when the octopi traveler 2 came out
there's just a lot of stuff that was on
at that time and you know part of me was
a little I'mma buy it on PC because I
ain't giving PlayStation my money oh my
Lord uh so I ended up still getting it
on Playstation but I gave GameStop my
money you get
gam yeah so you know what's funny
is I still have had to pay the the full
price now I think it was $5 less it was
it was uh 55 but like to me I was just
like I'd rather give GameStop my money
than than than PlayStation locking stuff
down behind walls and stuff oh Lord here
we go so yeah but I I want to say it's
like playing this game I remember how
good the first one was like it co Cog
remembers Cog was in a party when I was
fighting the last boss in octopath
traveler one like we're not talking like
the the the standard last boss we're
talking about like the last last boss
because there's a it's like one of those
scenarios where you have to do more
stuff to get to the last boss right and
the funny thing is when you fight
him they make you use all of your people
not just not just the people you picked
out what happens is there's like two
sections of the boss the top part fight
the top and the bottom fight the bottom
so that's what's up if you don't go
andev everybody and you jump out there
with them
bum what's funny is it's not lowl stuff
yeah high level so I had to literally
take the other people and level them up
to like 70 to 80 because I couldn't beat
either
level good for and it took me a minute
man like I'm I I actually have a a clip
on on Twitter of me beating this dude
and it was it was by the hair man
because this dude was hard hard I
remember what I do like about you adct
is the fact that if it's your game and
you care about it you going to do we
going do all the optional
stuff fact they make you do it
unfortunately like in order to get the
last boss you had to do all the option
but you could ended the game without the
last B right but I don't consider that
beating the game okay
okay it's it's like um Dragon Quest 12
11 you know you could beat the game but
if you want to beat the game you have to
do the last little bit to get the true
last boss interesting so that's been so
You' been playing anything else what
those going I've been playing a lot of
uh Persona tactica oh that tactica yeah
it's it's it's it's definitely an
interesting game what what I what I
enjoy about it is like they took the
formula from you know uh these these
turnbas grid style that's why I call
them turnbas grid style games you know
they they they kind of went more towards
a like what a um Mario Sparks and hopes
so like a rabbit field like a rabbit so
where you can walk around and it's not
just like move here right right right
there's a lot more options a lot more
free motion to it know you know what's
what I like about Persona tactica is
like they have actual you know they kind
of have like their own palaces their own
bosses and I I just recently fought a
boss that kind of felt like that that
energy that that uniqueness that their
palace bosses in five main line and
question like is it Canon to the story
of personal five so from what I'm seeing
and I maybe I'm getting this wrong but
it's after all the events of five and
then this happens gotcha oh we got okay
what I like is that you know a lot of
the times I play these type of games
it's okay you're doing this we're going
to do that exact thing right but when I
play this you know you got your personas
here so that's your management where you
combine personas to make it now they did
kind of mess with the lore a little bit
because generally the only person that
can switch more the only person that can
have more than one Persona is the main
antagonist because that's what makes him
unique compared to everyone else is he
could switch between between person well
they kind of get they kind of threw that
out the market like this doesn't happen
like everyone has a secondary Persona
all right so it's not just Joker
everybody you know what I like most
about it what game pass
that's what you like the most now you
interested hey man if I feel like
partaking man I'm I'm a part I feel yeah
but it's it's definitely a fun time you
know U I do think that they could have
told the narrative a little bit better
from what I'm playing I I think I'm
almost at the end I'm like 15 16 hours
in right uh but like how they normally
tell these type of games is like the
Sprites or however you want to pronounce
it like they're on the C they're on the
the the map and they move around they
give a lot of like emotions through
stuff like kind of like Final Fantasy
Tactics uh you know um oh the other one
that just came out recently they just
remade it I can't remember what it's
called Tac ogre oh Tactics Ogre T so
like there's a lot of you know emotion
on the field like they they tell it in
obviously it doesn't have like
cinematics but they do it in a way that
you could still feel the emotion a lot
of voice acting and here it's literally
just someone's talking on the left
someone's talking on the right and I
don't like those guys because I feel
like there's not a lot of emotions going
through those like every time I the
moment I see your game do that I
automatically like oh man like so you
need the cinemas you need the C no no
it's not that I need Cinemas I just I
need to see the people interacting on
the map
like punched I want to see it and like
Final Fantasy Tactics like they show
that like there's so many like betrayal
moments where people are getting stabbed
and and you hear like this cinematic and
and keep in mind back then it was
Sprites little Sprites like little
little joints yeah but they did more
with those little Sprites than these big
images just talking and there's not
really any lips moving it just
completely talking about about like the
picture of the anime and maybe eyes
might BL so you don't get no connection
to the Joint yeah but Tanga like it's
the cat that's in Persona 5 she's not as
tall as everyone else so she's just in
the middle of the of of the screen
talking because she's not is talk what I
noticed is they put the text on her feet
so it kind of like breaks the EM
emersion where she's just floating there
so you know besides that it's a fun game
it really is you know uh I've gotten to
the point where you know I I really
enjoy the the combat they have like the
in Persona for those who don't know once
you knock everyone down you have like
this this attack where it says all round
attack where everyone jumps in and just
starts beating the hell out yeah I like
that's that's the what I did at PA West
which they got all three jump jump
threat that's what it's called the only
way to get that is to knock someone down
and like these lines show up and you
have to angle
them and as long as they're in that line
everyone in that in that line is getting
dealt with and and sometimes you could
do some crazy stuff you kill like almost
everyone on the map just with that one
about salute Persona tactica out there
outside that's been it sir yeah that
that's been pretty much it you know I I
I'm probably going to once I finish
tactica because I'm think I'm really
close I don't know uh I'm going to go
and I'm really hit octopi traveler too
man like yeah I picked the the the
samurai dude because you uh for those
you don't know like on on these type of
Games you start with one character and
you have to go get the rest yeah yep
everyone has their own story like see
Coden yes yes yes yeah yeah like the the
character I'm using now the main
character I already have four or no
three characters but the main character
I'm using you know his his brother
portrayed everyone and and killed his
father and took over the kingdom and
they and they they kicked him out of the
kingdom and it was pretty much like I
like because once again like it shows
emotion even though it's like like these
high detailed cinematics you see the
emotion on the screen no I got it you
this way is the connection with you and
what's actually going on some stiff
around he's like he's like I know pretty
much said I know I can't take you on
right now brother so I'm going to come
back with people I'm going come back and
I'm going take my king chat said
spoilers yo they going in on literally
the first chapter of the first time on
you with your spoil yo they going
in but anyway other than that I K him
though I shouldn't have said that yeah
he was a little loose he was a little lo
you got too excited but it's all good
excited about he was very excited about
this it's all good and no doubt we know
s our technical law should join us in
progress but we have the The Incredible
Hulk of this aka the excess gamer ooh
the prophet of Xbox swamy King of the
statues who demands nothing less than
that premium experience it is the leader
of the Xbox front line movement woo look
at that background look at that
background Lord King how we doing I'm
doing fantastic I'm doing better than
Demetrius andrades uh andrades Yer got
uh
the fight stopped He Got tko'ed by David
benovitz he got TV turned off yeah yeah
no well no you know he was sitting in
his corner and he just took enough of a
beating for the referee to be like nah
bro no M okay got you this ain't your
night you just gonna sit down and um he
gave a valiant effort what I said in my
uh combat talk if you're a member of
Xbox Frontline I put a combat talk up
yesterday um on a members only Channel
and um I predicted that uh
Andrade would win would pull it out and
I I I predicted Charlo would win as well
Charlo did win he beat Char for yeah he
his his the one that got smacked yeah
the one that got smacked the one that
got smacked oh yeah by by Yeah by Caleb
you know Caleb R streets I was like D I
told you bro I told you don't don't
cheese me don't cheese me
bro real quick um kid smooth actually
officially like made it public you know
definitely gave some love to K smoo like
his grandma passed away like one of the
people that like raised smooth he's
going through a lot right now yeah s
love the kids move man for real out the
kid move for sure for sure yeah so you
know Charlo came back and um he it to me
it was a split decision because I
thought Jose did enough for at least one
uh uh scor card to reflect that that he
made a a closer fight but it really
wasn't a close fight in the eyes of the
judges so Charlo went away with it but
he didn't look there he looked off and
it's probably for the two years that he
hasn't been in the ring but uh David
benovitz is your night bro and hopefully
you do get that Canelo fight I don't
think Canelo is going to fight you I
think you you just going to have to
chalk that up as loss and find somebody
else to fight some bigger better fish
but um not that guy um what I've been
playing what you been rocking I felt
victim bro I felt victim to to to the
Black Friday play oh what you do you
little scoop you was outside my stupid
behind you know how you you you I'm
scrolling for no reason I go to game
pass I don't go to the store I don't
know why I collect the store because on
the dashboard they got me l a sinker
they was like yeah we got 50% off oh 50%
off hold on hold on what's these games
that's not on Game
Pass and I went there and I'm kind of
mad at Phil because I swear I I swear
Phil I swear if you do this you you set
me up you set me up I thought Valhalla
would be in game pass at some point in
time right oh boy yeah from the setup I
go out and get Valhalla Valhalla was 14
bucks okay so I was like um but for I
think it was 20 bucks for the whole
shebang okay so I said give me the whole
shebang right ul Ultimate deluxe edition
yeah all the DLC so I was like oh yeah
why why am I buying this game I ain't
going to have no time to play
it that's one that's that was one that
was one strike against me you know me
being a fraud acting like acting like I
could buy games I got TI right I got no
time
so so I'm like all right got that why
did I act like I secured something all
right so and then I ran for Killer
Instinct so sooner or later he gonna
have this Final Fantasy slander I'm just
waiting for it no no no no oh oh oh yeah
I was playing Final Fantasy this week
see here it is there you go right no no
mhm no um surpris you know what no
didn't it's inside my PlayStation Plus
bro stop don't play with me oh okay oh
Oh I thought you was playing it on oh I
they on Xbox but I okay exactly I
thought you was waiting so cuz it was on
Plus for free no so this is what
happened yeah why you adct was animant
that this game ain't the same yes and
I'm animant that it is oh okay you doing
one of us is wrong and one of us is
right and my thing is my thing is I
can't keep yelling at my brother right
he don't know what he's talking about
unless I know what I'm talking about
fair so I'm playing the game right at
the moment and at the moment it is beat
for beat step for step it
is about it's it's about 80% once you
hit that I mean it might even be 85%
because there's a point where it's like
you get in this Nostalgia and then
something happens like yo that didn't
happen that didn't happen before that
you going back and reversing the past
that's all that is that's that's you
saying that you you got a chance to look
at your your your Masterpiece script he
like I really didn't like how I put that
last bar in there you almost almost
switch that barall around it's gonna
really slap this time they ain't gonna
see this one coming that's that's
exactly what he did so I'm gonna play
this game and it's GNA be exactly what I
said it is if it's 85% the the dude like
if it's yo if you see 85% of the dude
that owe you money walking down the
street 85% of him that 85% got to Buck
up and pay you
back so don't tell
me it's 85% and and it's 15% is
different ah come on man anyway so you
going to see you going to see I'm see
I'm see what happens anyway playing
fortnite yeah um this game is crazy yeah
they keep updating crazy no it it's
something wrong with the fact that I
guess when they jump into a new season
and and so a lot of they things and and
not just the season they have this like
catastropic events right it's always a
medeor h the planet TV being turned out
or something and then the world comes
back different right so now the media is
about to hit the planet they have a CL
down countdown and all this but
different stuff keeps popping up in the
world that don't normally be there like
all of a sudden now you got a planes
that's outside or all of a sudden now
you have um balloons that you can get
and it's like a daily thing and I guess
they're doing this daily to keep
everybody off balance keep yeah the um
the the explosion hits but I'm down for
it me and sinister's been playing
heavily shout out to Sinister salute I
told him I said um because you know he
had to ask one time oh uh you know I
didn't want to jump in your party get in
there boy I'm like what the hell you
talking about we was swapping you know
uh changing diapers and stuff like that
as kids like what are you talking about
like we was sharing uh you know French
fries and stuff like twopiece the
chicken yeah so yeah so no you my
brother cut that out I'm like you're
jumping there so he's been jumping in he
ain't been playing nice so he de SI he
about his fortnite I know that he get
down on that he got a whole another
account I was like yo who is this
Sinister K2 and X1 and he's like that's
my fortnite account cuz I don't want to
lose my skins cuz I lost on this I'm
like oh my God yes he's hardcore I was
talking with him this week I was like yo
he hardcore with it yeah he taught me
how to um that thing that you just yeah
that that was yeah whatever y'all doing
with skins and all
that no no I was just playing Mario's
mushrooms is to as well I was playing um
Alan Wake 2 and I'm trying to finish the
Call of Duty campaign nice nice I much
stuff am I the only one that feels
overwhelmed by how many games it's too
many it's too I've sitting here like I
picked up octopad traveler 2 so I'm
playing that after I play Persona
tactica and then after that I got to go
back to Mario wonders and then after
that I got to beat Mario RPG which I'm
probably going to beat that before
before that then after that I got to go
back to Assassin's Creed Mirage then
after that I got to go to like nonstop
it's that space I didn't
play I got got I still got to do Phantom
Liberty after for me I got c
punk a live bending the KN what's going
on what happen what did I what did I
earn what did I earn I got I got been an
what's going on talk to me talk to me
let's get it out let's get it out
brother all right I got to eat something
all right right all right all right all
right you know you got to act tough all
right you don't want to cry is waging
what
happened um I went to go see the Marvels
again this weekend
Oh get out of here this is wild let me
okay let me hear this someone CL someone
stopped the tape stop the tape cuz last
last couple weeks I got I got killed by
K no I wasn't killing you per se because
you don't you know you don't follow no
you you was upset you right you was
upset with certain things but set with
uh a certain movement that was trying to
um piggyback on something else and try
to pull somebody else into it and try to
blame the other people like no it's not
them it's not us it's them type of thing
I didn't like that and no it's clearly
you now them same things is still there
okay okay okay removing that away from
the film um and my personal bias now I
went as RNR with the Lords King okay
okay now I got to I got to watch the
movie on his Merit not king that loves
yeah like comic book accurate you got
every book King from stanlee from the
jump yeah yeah he had to stay home and
um I watched the film and I thought
everything that you said was true they
fleshed out the character more they gave
her more emotion they gave her more
range they gave her more feeling um they
put different layers on Captain Marvel
to make it seem that she's not um
greater than that she is the average
woman that do love and her her loving
actually put them in that um predicament
understand that Monica Rambo uh how her
thing is I also um uh this girl um yeah
I know talking about Miss Marvel fan
girl Jersey City in the building but
she's like fan girl and oh my God I got
but but she has to do a job at the same
time corre and then Nick Fury navigating
the stuff that he has to navigate so he
was uh delegating people to do certain
things that he couldn't do at that time
because he had to worry about the space
station um my overall assessment of the
film mhm after cuz my first uh
assessment of the film was a one popcorn
yeah I know you was was so my overall
assessment and I'm going do RNR this
week we need to see that feed the
streets Fe the um but my overall um
assessment of the film I now give it a
three star all right that's all I said
all I said I it was better than the
first one for me and they just fleshed
her out with the other two I felt you
know what I'm saying and I'm with you
there like but all the other stuff I
felt that you had critic
I thought I thought was accurate so I
respect that what's Up's up I was just
like I got to tell my brothers
appreciate you I was heartbroken yeah I
feel you no I feel trust me I'm worried
right now cuz I'm hearing surf rumors I
don't want to hear but we G to move on
so
any I'm going to assume that's Nova and
I'mma let them Rock and I'mma assume
they yeah Juno or Juno there you go and
of course we have the G ninja himself
the shinovi Lord Cognito right that real
to the IOP I tell you what you want to
what you need to shout out to Mr Matty
play Shout out to fining dke we was
talking you know just catching up on
what's going on with cotour and he's
very emotional we talk about that's one
of our topics today shout out to the
last wordy Bond Tai got trapped little
holiday take a little break off for the
Thanksgiving so we should be back you
know new season you know what I'm saying
next week as far as games finished like
a dragon giden so I was very happy to do
that um beef is over
frud now you good beef is over kiru fans
you know what I'm saying y know I'm team
ichy Bond all day every day he's the
future of the series turbas the future
of the series but as a person who is
still fairly new to kiru this story was
so gangster and I like the way he carry
it I like the way he carry he's a really
he's a smooth dude but he's honorable
there's about two scenes in this game
King where it was some real like it was
some Mafia joint that went like you know
why I like the story on this they
keeping it real like what's going on
right now you can't be Yakuza you can't
be mob cuz the government is here and
they slapping y'all with d Rico so they
like so this is not a major spoiler no
I'm laughing tell me how pulled up S
pulled up as the leaker he's the
leak he pulled up I'm in I'm in my
leaker guard right now yeah yeah yeah
like what did I do where am I who am I
running from right now yeah so you ought
a move again that was hilarious how he
came through but yeah sorry no no you
good you so what I would say is for me I
like the true to life um you know the
way they depicted the mob how they going
to have to try to out with the
government by quote unquote breaking it
up so they ain't getting corrupted so
that joint right there and there's some
there's like two scenes where I ain't
going to front and he like you you know
the scene is good when you know that the
character is going to be okay but in
that scene is done so you like oh oh and
it was some real yo fam you got to do
what you got to do you know what I'm
saying I'm I'm good with regard
regardless to whatever you do so the way
he hold it the way he keep it and then
the end again giving proper context to
why he's doing the things he doing why
he is the man who erased his name why he
he he did it all this for a reason and
it's so honorable right and in the end
something happened regarding that reason
and he get information on it and he
break down so much you make make you
want to break down so now that's my
man's CUO yeah shout out to Cipher kiru
is awesome beef is over I ain't got KIRO
fans you ain't got to comfor me I am Tim
ichon but I rock with son that's my
brother we going to do and then I
unlocked the infinite weal Voice come
out you going to still rock all right so
let's get to it let's get to it let's we
got to talk about it so in in
guid you've officially heard his Dove
then right yes now I because all right
when you play Guiden it's not available
you have to go
right that's K you there now you unlock
the infinite wealth demo it tells you do
you want to do English I said I said
let's just do it because I lead Ichi
bong English that's how I met Ichi bong
that's my dude Kai Kang right right
bilingual right no doubt so I will say
adct yeah like I still hear young yay
YouTuber just being honest right so it's
taken me a little while now I will say
the way they link is is is lit the you
go there's a reason why everybody's in
Hawaii and Hawaii is super lit and I
will say turnbas is so much better for
the kiru fans who like traditional beat
him up old school streets R he got three
fighting styles of this he don't have to
fight turnbas in the turn base he could
move around do what he want to do with
his spoilers it's not a
spoiler it's literally a feature a
so anyway like I would say that's all I
would say but it it is super fun and
super dope if there there's going to be
some I'm going to give young a chance
and play through but there's going to be
some controversy on people already know
they ain't going to like it they like
nah we going to switch it my one thing
with uh Final Fantasy is that it's not
turnbas like I don't have the option to
do that and that kind of infuriates the
hell out of me I feel like and and the
reason why turnbas is the future for the
series they could do so much there's a
new character is like last thing I said
this man is a Uber
driver his super move is to lock you in
the Uber have you swerving and you like
oh my God you got the boss screaming for
his life then he take the Uber off a
cliff jump out does a front tuck
somersault and in the back with the
Cinematic the Uber blow up and he like
yeah taxi ride from Hell or whatever his
super you can't do this in regular if
you can't if it's not turbas you can't
do it it is the greatest joint going so
salute infinite wealth I can't wait one
of my most anticipated joints going in
and of course joining us live from snit
Central underground
bunker the most technical gaming Lord
the solo gamer who lives with a single
player selfish experience and also the
Sous the Lord of clarity and Lord
patreon of the iron bank PC Master race
oh show us your build Lord
S I can always count on you guys to
still be in intros no matter how late
Ive I like there still in intros
especially if King was able to make King
was able to make it I'm like oh I'm good
no no I just I just made sure to um hold
it out no it's really adct ad was
talking
about thank you appreciate it yes yes um
yeah man it's been it has been a week
and it is going to continue to be a
month so is just is what it is but yeah
a little bit under the weather it was
not able to play
um as much as I thought I would be able
to play over the over the break um but I
am I think I'm in the end game right now
of Spider-Man 2 I'm kind of there I'm
kind of there get finished okay yeah F I
know right like's see some credits on
the game I need some credits let's go so
I got to ask King a question here this
isn't a spoiler L I'm just going to say
it vaguely so King the the stuff that's
happening is I was again I was there
when when McFarland created like Venom
and in the beginning but I don't
remember specific story lines I remember
the main symbiote storyline right the
stuff that's happening in this story is
this something that they created for
themselves or this idea this this idea
of what what literally happens in this
story has been told in the books well no
well it's been told in the books what um
what they did was Insomniac went and got
the prevalent Venom books right all of
them and kind of put them all together
Cliff note all of them and said okay we
got the main points and we're going to
wrap it up and we're going to make our
own story and I think they did pretty
good with their own story being that
they don't have multiple years to tell
you this story like you know comic books
that story line went on for multiple
years a couple of them right yeah so
okay but it's really good stuff it was
it was good yeah Ian I saw I was like
damn this is this is this is elevated
from what I remember exactly yeah yeah
like some of this stuff was super op
like how is he doing this yeah yes
exactly okay I'm enjoying it still like
the combat's still great um some of the
cool upgrade stuff that I'm seeing is
very cool um that's pretty much it a
little bit more Mario that's about it um
I'm you know what I'm excited to watch I
don't know if you guys have been paying
attention to it the iron
claw that is just that is uh it has Zack
Efron in it okay he plays I believe it's
David von Eric it's the story of the Von
Erics oh old Von Texas tornado in them
Texas tornado you know that they their
life has had like I mean that that
family
had tragedy after so he is the only
Survivor wow and this is the story he's
the one that used to wrestle Barefoot
yes yes yes yes I remember him so it's
his story they saying Zach efon has play
played like a ridiculous role in this um
like he like physically looks the role
or whatever and that story has always
been intriguing to me because they were
like you know we back in the day we used
to love Texas tornado car I remember the
music yeah man so and the fact is that
family has seen tragedy up and down um
and actually I didn't realize this I
think Carrie's daughter was wrestling
with ww at some point I don't know if
she's still there or maybe she's with a
or TNA right now but she wrestled yeah
um I never KN that okay so yeah it's
just it's a story that always intrigued
me because it was so sad and especially
again I remember it through the lens of
Carri specifically he was he was really
prominent during when we were being yeah
cuz I was war fan and when he came up he
he had his run I think he had
Intercontinental Championship run it was
a BRI for a little bit yeah for a little
brief M that whole family is cursed
that's the thing it say like they're
cursed right yeah they cursed and have
this one family member this one son that
survived and uh this sucked because I
was like fans of all of themed off they
were great they were great and it was
you know whether it was like you know
you know different things accidents but
it all sort of stem back to mental
health overall a lot of it is kind of
focused on the fact that their dad was
super hard on them to get them to be
great you know um so I'm excited to
watch that movie when it comes out it
was in previews I thought it was out but
it's it actually comes out the same day
or comes out the same weekend that
Aquaman comes out so got oh yeah time to
watch that pull up for the Aquaman joint
no doubt yeah for me the last thing I
did forget was I'm playing on the new
Diablo season and the vampire just kind
of because I think it's like a triple XP
week it's actually pretty fun man I
really enjoying what they're doing you
know season is rocking and keep that
triple XP cuz I can level up super fast
and do what I need to do but yeah I'm
I'm I think I'm team Necromancer now yo
I ain't going to front like I like have
my little goons with me sending them out
you you can play by yourself don't need
no help I have like 30 dudes walking
down the street and I just keep raising
them from the day I got you raise them
up I got the joint where the the corpses
when you raise them up from I stick out
the tendil and cold you and keep them
there and they get dizzy and do other
stuff evil stuff so yeah yeah yeah I'm
definitely killing it on that and then I
think the new Dy season is next week and
I'll start back that but I want to frock
out with Diablo Diablo is another game
that I I ordered early I dude I had
Early Access I turned it on that's it as
a matter of fact no I I install battl
net so I can play and that was it that
was you stupid thing I did no no I
remember you had some issue with it like
you had like no no no not not that I did
the dumbest thing I went and brought uh
Valhalla yeah Val how the longest game
going cuz it was Black Friday sale I me
how much how much you get it for 20
bucks you for the whole sh bang for the
whole I mean n it's absolutely worth it
it it's it's just the thing that is like
be ready for 150
hours going play it though this is and
right and this is and this is base game
they haven't not even with the additions
of it like facts yeah it got too crazy
before we get into I'm sorry guys please
no no please what do we have some wild
going oh since you've returned
um things have happened in the chat have
you guys read any we have not read any
just yet okay so just get ready or if
you want to do that you want me to do
the patreon questions while you get
ready uh let's do this cuz this is okay
yeah very ex question very excitable
right now all right let's let's put the
crest in the chat for Lord silver twank
89 whoa twank hello TR
hello then we have a member for 23
months hindsight with hustle Lord bronze
hello everyone H as well shout out to
you hustle what's going on let's put the
question in the chat once again for
Edward Walton welcome to the realm Lord
bronze thank you appreciate Lord that's
right then we got geek to sneak M for
one Lord bronze Ayo yeah you know you
know a bunch of AOS are
coming why that's our crowd a bunch of
AOS are coming for the course see that
is bunch of
Goo then we got let's put the CR in the
chat for Lord bronze timer 21 shout out
to Temp Sal salute then we got David hot
rght member for 25 months Lord silver
dance dance yeah some
dance by certain dance Lord I'm I'm
watching it right now it is going all
over
Twitter what I forgot what was that it
was a Let's Dance it was a PS1 game that
had it was a dancing game and it had a
dude that looked like Disco Inferno and
it was like I'm the natural
Playboy what is you
s I got to look for you got to find that
yeah you got to find that we definitely
got to find that that's wow you know
what's funny uh when I left I was like
yeah I was like U you know Grace wants
me uh to to get off and he's like yeah
man he's like uh I see you tomorrow I
was like yeah she came in here when we
were dancing and she was like you know
what what's going on he's like what's
going
on and I what's funny is is she she's
like what are you doing I was like she's
oh you're on you're on Alex's podcast
okay now it makes sense okay so the game
was bust a
Groove and the song was the natural
Playboy oh man yeah gotta get that for
you no thank you back to you back to you
so then we got let me see we got Robert
Kell $2 Super Chat adct started the only
fans damn listen man got to make that
money anywhere you can man what is with
the obsession this community has me
starting a only fans you be telling
people we leave the door open
sleep don't ask
surprise back to you
son then we got Doctor Strange Love $2
Super Chat adct was throwing it back to
back last night
wow D not the back to back adct throwing
it back the
back I ain't GNA lie man there's very
few people that would have convinced me
to dance all on stream but Alex somehow
became one of them Alex is he just he he
hyped me up the dance somehow I don't
know how he did it he's like he's like
it's time M it's
time he wasn't he said something about a
$50 super was that true someone someone
donated $50 Super Chat for us to dance
they they they was making it rain in
that club for
him yeah and now different Alex in
laughing right now I see
him then we got Robert kellet $2 Super
Chat sa on the run from strange strange
glove that's funny that's a funny take
on that name the strange glove wow and
joystick yes yes I'm on the run on the
Run don't need to shout me yeah and we
got David hotti $20 Super Chat we need
loget game awards for the
people that's coming that's coming on
Lords gaming.net check that out the
Riders the team they are doing the game
of the year pick so yeah come check that
out man the gold the golden Lance golden
Lance awards are returning make sure you
check out Lords gaming.net mm is up in
there I saw him early we got things
cooking y'all and we got Doctor Strange
Love Again $5 uh Super Chat I'm seeing
this outcry of people call calling
sequels DLC and I'm wondering why is it
because sequels are further apart now
and people expect more Innovation I
think you just answered your question it
is true like when you have a game that
takes five to six years to make now and
The Innovation you could see it you know
you can it is literally you know just a
take on that first game which again you
expect the sequel to be that but with
that much distance between games you
expect it to feel different you expect
you expect to be more Wild by the
product and it know so this is the just
tell say the real when you used assets
from the first game when you literally
us assets from the first game exactly
you're a DLC that's it yeah I I think
you know hey don't want to spend that
money I get you I get
it yo these super chats are wild for
shout out to Craig hooligan gifting one
one IP membership appreciate salute
salute then we got robot
octopus
5 pound Super Chat Lords tin foil hat
time balers gate three for Xbox no
preorders announcement teased for game
awards will it Shadow drop on Game Pass
am I crazy I said that already you've
been watching get we GNA get yeah we GNA
get to that topic because hey it is
interesting how they they promoting
right we'll see we'll
see then we got country big
94 happy Sunday to everyone currently
backst is getting ready for my match but
still wanted to show my support to the
Lords PS K you number one
forever no that cut you salute yo check
out his page he out here doing the
wrestling match for Real so
real he just did a match yeah he did a
match it was official and I told you the
beef is over yeah ich K you my brother
now so don't even worry the beef is over
I finish like a dragon gu we good
salute then we got uh P 155 3D M for
four months Lord bronze happy for IL as
I drive from ATL back to the shy oh
salute safe travels brother hopefully we
can yeah safe travels hope we can
accompany you yeah those are the best
time listen to a long form podcast is on
the road I ain't going to for it's super
super entertaining then we got nintend
theotaku remember of a six months Lord
Silver N we gonna keep this beef
alive wait who's that who's that who
that this is donut T he still got beef
for CUO if you rock with car you ich
bong gang ain't rocking with
you you ain't allowed in the hood No
More n n yeah I got a hood pass I got a
hood pass I've been on Team ich listen
man we got to let it go bro kiru is the
homie that's all I'm you got he been
through some things man he been through
some things it's all over bro we gang
Now official we UniFi put our flags
down then we have Doctor Strange Love
Again here we go
who are you running from sa joystick did
he hurt you get away from that boring
old joystick and get with a Pro
Controller like yo the Pro
Controller King I need to beat for
that I don't even hear it so
whatever I don't even know what's going
on until I watch the show back
[Laughter]
so can't hear my voice and we got we fix
that let's play with each other's
joysticks Super Chat the battle Z ain't
running from me he's running to
me ain't nobody worried about your mad
cat's
controller he said drop that zero and
get with the
zero I only have an elite joystick for
y That's it right there he that right he
got the
elite man thank you thank you for your
kind patri
to
verbally I am so happy that is not
nothing to do with me that has
everything to do with solve and
edct Halo reach around where you at baby
oh man that's that's attic B then we got
geek the sneak $5 Super Chat let's go
I'm a turn-based final fantasy fan but
to be honest I really enjoyed 16 I think
it was because of the game Game of
Thrones style story yeah I like that I
like it Final Fantasy that's the only
like positive thing you can take from 16
is I feel like it was the first like
really mature not all of them have been
mature but this is like the first one to
really like push it push it like like
there's literally been final fantasies
where they've killed I remember like the
scene from Final Fantasy 7 like the the
original one where he woke up in the
prison and his blood all
like there has been like tones like this
but this is the first time they put it
in modern final yeah shout out shout out
to the dominants I like when they say
that you can you beat their dominant the
dominant the dominant continue I didn't
like I love
it it's like a huge like Naro presence
yeah Nar and they rough with they stuff
yeah it's why I like it it's like it's a
arms race yo they got two dominants over
there you know what I'm saying like you
got to have that to compete with your
country like I don't know just funny to
me it's like nuclear warheads the
dominance yeah that's what they are
basically
basically I think they still left from
the boys be honest with you because in
the boys remember when uh vot would have
different Heroes for different countries
yep y I got you let me see then we have
Simon Brandy with the five pound Super
Chat digital foundaries review of PS
portal just exposed IGN's eight out of
10 I guess it must be that play guess it
must be that PlayStation rebate shout
out to King loving his new channel
blessings thank you sir front line line
then we got di down anime remember for
three months Lord bronze when we doing
fight nights I'm trying to hand King
this his L's and Killer Instinct oh
Fight Night listen we ain't gotta wait
for nothing You See Me online all the
time Boe smoke is free for the uh you
know Cog briefly mentioned it
we are going to be taking a huge portion
of December off for for our break yes
and I was talking maybe me and King
comes on like one of those days we're
not doing it and do like a fight night
to like give an example of what these
fight nights will be next year because
we're not really launching Fight Night
to its to its highest until next year
but maybe if me and King have some time
we'll do you know I won't be
participating if we can do if I if I
have the time on a Saturday or something
we'll I'll jump on and we'll do a one I
I will cuz come January it's going to be
Tekken and probably nothing else I I
will be watching from the
sidelines this Thanksgiving I I had to
you know spank a lot of people you know
was over they thought that you know old
dude you know lost his moves or
something like now this is my controller
you gonna get this work get this work
what else we got then we got Doctor
Strange Love once again $5 Super Chat
your abuse and exploitation of sa ends
here joystick
he don't need a PlayStation Edge like
you like like you he needs an Xbox Elite
2 with extra
vibration hey yo that's crazy they
getting real with this once again thank
you for your
patrons then we have Belo member for 27
months Lord bronze yeah big fan of the
Von Erics can't wait to see the story
The epitome of over in Texas EX exactly
uh y'all keep killing it love the Lord's
King WIS Fight Night same thing got got
it we got it we want it combat talk
that's in the members only join the
members and you can see combat talk
there it is she heard it first it
here let's play with each other's
joysticks once again $ five Super
Chat Sab needs a more immersive and
handson experience and I got that VR
while you still
pancaking you nothing but a groupy who
jumped on the B yo he called him a fake
s fan yo a groupy he a groupy that's wow
you don't even know his middle
name Elite standing you don't even know
my
birthday yo who said that know my
birthday I forgot that's wild that's
wild we is in California somebody said
that yeah thank you for supporting
appreciate that um then we have Danny
passion official $5 Super Chat my wife
is not a gamer but sometimes she said
she sits down with me to watch while I
play games with great stories she puts
60 plus hours watching Yakuza seven so
yeah salute salute got that
ich and we got I let put the crest in
the chat for the homie hary chanani
gifting 10 I memberships thank you
brother appreciate salute thank you
brother that's appr man much love to GE
then we have yeah baby fa $2 Super Chat
I still got smoked for Destin 2 wow yes
I heard Street I heard some heard some
things yes a lot of lot of attacks in
the
streets you know when when you part of a
certain cabal oh my God you guys you got
to act like murder no n us what you
crazy I did I did try to get in his
stream
yesterday y m yeah he wasn't let me in
there I W cross the stream oh
wow no I forgot who it was I saw
yesterday on Twitter there was somebody
there somebody who follows us on Twitter
I forgot who it is he's a Dev or he's a
Dev at a small uh sort of development uh
group but um he I guess he used to work
on bigger games or whatever and he I
love the way he broke it down because he
broke it down about you know okay maybe
the the verbiage of tax is is what
is yes yeah we three talking we going to
get him in real man we got yeah no I
think BR it down I like I like his break
down was is like okay all of these
things together feel like there's a bias
and I can't say that people are wrong
for saying that so they tagged me in it
and was like yo these are good
counterpoints and I said absolutely I
said I said three bits only thing is I
he we were arguing different things on
Duke I was just talking about game
awards dominations and we talk about Jas
we were I never discussed the the tax
part yet but it was great though we
going to have him on to talk about the
textbooks I like a lot of stuff he was
saying yeah yesterday when I was talking
to Paris and Alex it's like you know
even if these people don't have the
intentions of attacking the Xbox brand
like in the media they're still being
extremely unprofessional in the media
and and to
me it should be talked about like it's
not something that should just be igned
like I think how many more times do we
going to keep hearing the words well
don't follow that media Outlet don't
listen to that review but these people
this conglomerate especially someone
like IGN they have a massive influence
in the industry massive and it's like to
ignore that is like to me it shouldn't
be ignored because at the end of the day
like the these people can influ that
they have such a pulse on the industry
right and you can't just let people run
wild like that like you just can't now
obviously for the people going extra
there's definitely people people out
disrespectful fam's death and all this
other pocket red dragon was out there
catching that
work Dron was like why kill me you need
to relax everybody got to chill yeah
with all this disrespectful like you
don't you don't need to say anything
crazy like un un let not bring up people
who passed away and all this other stuff
like yeah it's just wild disrespectful
and look at the end of the day we all
everybody's got their feeling but you we
got to be respectful y'all cuz it makes
us look crazy both sides when we get
disrespectful we can had a conversation
just be respectful yeah that's theane
what else we got okay we got fors a
legend remember for 47 months Lord
bronze only auma would anybody on it
would kill I guess kill anybody on that
Tekken roster remember only Akuma fought
a on the moon and on Akuma split the
moon in half just saying Street Fighters
King there we go with this aggressive
Steve and violent Ken and Oni Akuma bro
he was in Tekken 7 we saw him we fought
him none of that death no blow up
senstive subject for call cuz it's funny
what's funny is the crossover happened
already and they man did not do he got
simply dismissed out devil
K why would you bring in some
side your whole right they said that
Kuma is Tekken lore I hear you yeah they
literally to Capcom though this can't
end it all right remember it was
supposed to be uh Tekken X fighter and
and uh Street Fighter X Tekken did
Street Fighter ever get their game out
the door um the Street Fighter X Tekken
came out but never teing X Street
Fighter cuz it almost put them out of
business it put back they out he like no
we're not doing it what was the ending
of that story and that will answer that
question it was a fake story when they
was working together with some CU oh so
at the end they work together yeah they
just work together it wasn't no we but
that's it it's nice so the equal guys
that's it yeah that's it they your man
came in there for to a draw and before
before devil J that's it and devil J
ain't even the strongest dude in the
Tekken roster by the way so continue you
have you have devils and you have a
demon a demon and we got dudes that get
rid of demon powers we got Jun gazar get
your demon out here we got Exorcist to
get all your demons out and turn you
normal but we going to keep it going we
going to keep it
going there we have then we have you
can't you can't find me in the bushes
with a two pound Super Chat hey I'm
still here I guess he's still in the
bushes so still in the bushes shout out
to you then we have Michael Mooney five
pound Super Chat here's some cash for
the Sony bail out fund I guess wow
wow then we got drive by Joe $5 Super
Chat do things when you want me to like
uh controller controller
whoa
controller
controller all right then we got Dr
Strange Love once again $ five Super
Chat Sav don't need VR what he truly
needs is something handheld and I got
something thick and long that will fit
in his hands
perfectly stay away from my boo wow
that's
crazy I am so lucky that my family if
your family and your wife all my my my
peers at work my
bosses little does he know it's one of
them probably it's probably them
trolling me then we got Suicide Kings
member for 36 months Lord bronze addict
stop ducking the smoke how many likes do
we need for you to do the official ILP
dance on stream oh n I'm not
embarrassing myself unless there's
monetary value monary there's no am of
likes I'd have to I'd have to be able to
to to to take myself out to eat and cry
my tears away from that embarrassment
okay door for Coco I'll be right back
yeah yeah do your thing you guys say
want me Dan n I'm G need I'm G need
someone hit my PayPal up for some
nonsense like that yeah heard him throw
it
up
then we have yeah baby fa once again $5
Super Chat homeboy double dipping pause
get Xbox fans red up for engagement then
do another stream asking for proof that
debunks his
nonsense wow wow lot L lot of beef in
the street right now crazy out here it's
crazy then we got Dwayne Kito $55 Super
Chat I heard from a JP investor that
Sony may go into
bankruptcy dude this if this happens oh
my
God never the end of it ever never ever
these people what's the PayPal name
relax guys David hot rght is on
it then we have said WEAU up scared yeah
you know they they will reach goals here
in the realm know that's you know happen
yes we've happened tattoos one chip
challenges and all type of stuff all
that kind of St patreon questions are in
shout out to Lord galston uh with the
investor tweet from yesterday do you
believe this may be what Jim was
referring to when he said if we lose
quality Duty PlayStation will never
recover again this is kind of what the
um that that Insider tweet that remember
adct you put in our our chat and you was
just like they might you know know P ps6
so do you believe uh this is what Jim
was referring to if he lose Cod no I
don't I don't okay so I think oh sorry I
think he was just I mean he might have
said this is it for me because he might
have took the stance that this ain't
gonna happen I don't know but right you
know I I think Jim knows that Call of
Duty is a huge thing to their bottom
line so PlayStation might have to Pivot
off of stuff and maybe he's referring to
that that's saying you know we can't
rely on Call of Duty for our you know
our our multiplayer experience anymore
we're going to have to actually invest
in other stuff I mean they got all these
games as a service some of them being
canceled some of them still coming out
you know maybe the writing's been on the
wall for a minute I don't know like Sol
is that what Jim was referring to no not
at all I think I think adct kind of hit
it on a a t there it was to me it was
never to me it was never going to be
that serious again he it might have been
for him because the thing about it that
Cod money is Laten money they don't have
to do anything for that
that is M that was free 99 money just by
the virtue of being the most popular
platform where you know that's it they
don't even maintain anything they
literally just let them sell it on their
store that is all and that was just
money coming in so anytime you have
money like that taken away from you yeah
because you one thing is you can't count
on that 70% just for just for putting it
on their account precisely you know and
the thing about it is you don't ever
count on money that's not you generating
it that's
right here you go don't ever do that
don't ever do that I to me you know you
you have to be the product when the
night the side stuff coming in I don't
care how much it is that's nice when did
we learn that when did Microsoft learn
that may they learn that oh my Lord they
learned
that one generation Max Spencer said uh
not today no more yeah they they had a
different kind of humbling experience
like yeah you know Sony's never had an
issue having their first party make
stuff they they do do second party stuff
but they their biggest IPS come from
them and Microsoft kind of did the other
way around where they would contract
other people to make their big games
besides like Halo gears and forz and and
after that that you know humbling
experience they're like it feels like
never again like well well the thing
with that is you know um you understand
your deficiencies if you want to survive
in this Marketplace you have to fix that
and you have a a foe as formidable as
Sony you understand you got to do what
you got to do and it was doing
underhanded tactics that stuff came out
but um yeah I don't think you GNA
survive this
fight and there's King's assessment and
at the end of the day the metrics that
that like to Phil's point when he says
I'm not going to Out PlayStation
PlayStation those metrics the console
sales and stuff that is still going to
look great on the PlayStation side but
ultimately st came out st came out man
feel I'm just saying I feel you I feel
you but at the end of the day that's
still going to favor PlayStation right
true but all this other stuff all this
other stuff that they're not really as
well prepared for as Microsoft is that's
going to really start rearing his head
at some point um whether it it matters
in the long term but again Microsoft is
fine they're fine not winning the
whatever the the whatever the the the
the public forward- facing fight is or
whatever the case may be but uh yeah
this stuff
if Jim really relied that much on COD
money and thought that was just a done
deal a bag and it goes to it goes to the
point where it all of them thought it
was to be a cold day in hell when
Microsoft owned activis yeah I think the
re they know how our wallet Rock our
wallet well it's it's not that they've
always they've always known Microsoft
had access to like this massive bank
account it's just no one up and to that
points ever made a move on a what it is
that's that's not it they always looked
at Xbox as a sucker right who wasn't
using their money right because you saw
Sony PlayStation right you saw uh
Nintendo switch whatever you know
Nintendo's the house right it was never
Microsoft Xbox always Xbox by itself he
out his father got money but this kid
kid is just you know
yeah he's he's the stepchild that isn't
acknowledged like he's out of out of
wedlock baby oh he's that kid he's you
know a side side piece baby baby so when
he got the air of the purse strings
stuff different they never thought he'd
be able to do it old old Xbox would
never be able to do it this Xbox sa in
the when sa is the most gangster dude he
throw the hoodie on and said we want
competition let us have
competition like like yo that's like
your pops telling
you I don't care if you fight I just
want to pick up the
winner that's what he's telling you so
he's telling Phil do what you
must I back you
fully M these dudes is done son I can't
I cannot wait to get do these topics
baby I know we got more patreon
questions to get
through yeah literally um I'm waiting
for more uh sources on said invested
tweet that's all I'm waiting for um if
play G Lord gal said again if
PlayStation is going to count the
PlayStation portal as a console does
that mean they plan to update the system
if possible for cloud streaming in the
future how should Microsoft count
console sales now anything that has game
pass on it is now a console TV own
handheld
PC thoughts addict King well King wants
to jump in clearly uh who yo I mean you
know gavon to be honest with you I think
that is part and parcel for how they've
been fudging the numbers for years right
so what we've seen now that fudging the
numbers has edged them over to the side
of bankruptcy right like they they they
staring at their mortality in the face
like
so it's cool that they do that Microsoft
isn't going to count those numbers or
inflate those numbers for what reason
there's no end goal to it they actually
show you what their financials and
everything are so yeah they understand
that they're not going to sell consoles
that way but if Microsoft was to come
out with that little streaming device is
that going to be C uh uh is it going to
be an accessory is it going to be
counted as a console and I think that'll
be counted as a console but something
that does not have console like
qualities and you can't like have it
play as it own that's a that's conundrum
because you have what is that g thing um
what gForce now gForce now no not gForce
now that that handheld Logitech
G gcloud that g-cloud is considered a
console and technically it does sort of
close to the same stuff not the same
because you can download stuff to it I
think that's the only uh differenti
factor to it so they should have counted
as a controller like accessory but
counting it as Hardware they got to show
that they won Black Friday they got to
show that they winning holiday so how
they do it no doubt anyone else on this
or St I like I mean this is this is
premium PlayStation Petty this this is
them doing okay because what they're
going to do is if they because according
to them it's sold very well yeah so they
want to show at least that month a
couple of months where it's like oh this
accessory is out selling your actual
console stuff like that so it feels like
pre PlayStation Petty move but at the
end of the day it's foul because it is
not a console unto itself if you told me
that the PlayStation portal could access
the
PSN and ps+ on its own off of a server
and off of a server you could stream
those games onto the portar then then I
would consider it a console a platform
unto itself it is not that you need a
PlayStation play to exist it's a
conduit Remote Play remot play so it's
just knowing that and them doing that
that is that's a sh move but it's it's a
sh move that classic PlayStation 4 Xbox
one generation boot on the neck
PlayStation does just to to to show yeah
um so it's just funny to me but it's
it's they should not be doing that not a
console it's something that you tell
investors to make you know numbers look
good and inflated whatever but I will
say to gl's question I do think it's
Poss possible they could update for
cloud streaming because I don't think
I'm of the firm believer that the Azure
partnership that they had with Mar over
is over after the ABK dirt slinging
started happening so my my guess is they
will either do their own thing or mess
with Amazon wasn't they with Amazon
Iona went back to Amazon so I think in
the future because we do know that they
are invested in the clouds a little bit
now and I think maybe they bring some
type of streaming you know in in in
conjunction with that as well as opposed
to having to remote in to your
Playstation per se right to do that I I
personally feel like they knew the
PlayStation guys would buy this so they
like if they if they pay sell it but the
thing about it is that at that point
once they do that then they open the
door to have to sell ps+ and the PSN as
a platform and then not have people
buying your buying your game's peac meal
right because at that point I can see
Sony being like well yeah maybe you can
log into this level of PS of PS plus you
can access these games on the cloud but
our premium first party games or
whatever nah there's no Cloud you can't
do that unless so unless you unless you
somehow can prove you have a PlayStation
5 yeah so to me they they should do that
I don't know how quickly they they want
to move into that realm because then
they really have to start thinking like
Xbox right without creating that
differentiation that they have so I
don't know I I don't know where they you
know Jim's gone so maybe maybe that's
what they're thinking I don't know I
have no idea two more patreon questions
we they going to be going right with
Jim two more patreon questions shout out
to Lord user not found hope everyone is
enjoying this Sunday so far just wanted
to ask a question about how the Lords
feel the Xbox games lineup will look in
2024 out of what we know or is announced
or perhaps what we we should know like
the ordering in wi the order in which
the games come out there was a slip up
from Matt booty which indicated that
aura and toborn come out and then later
is hellblade to do they do that before
the actual June showcase or will
hellblade come out literally later in
the year where does a vow or some other
speculating games fall into this
regardless I hope all is well in the
realm and enjoy the holidays regardless
if you celebrate so what do we think
start with ad what do you think as far
as the order of 2024 games do you think
hellblade 2's later do you think vow
coming any other speculated games for
their lineup in 2024 I don't even think
they know right now think they don't
know I think they got an ideal like a
window where these games are coming out
out but idea we going to get you to say
idea one
day n I'm going fight I'm fight I'm
fight I'mma reup I'm back on back on the
battle now with CI yeah just
I I know how to say it but you ain't
getting me to say it that is so rude at
this point is it just belligerent on his
explain to me how you telling me how to
speak is rude to
you well I got to hear it he's like got
got I I do feel that they will I I do
think they're going to have a really
good
2023 I believe yeah 2024 I think we're
gonna get avowed
probably like around E3 time I think
we'll see hellblade before
E3
and part of me thinks they're gonna drop
Indiana Jones next holiday oh yeah yeah
part of me thinks that like there's a
strong possibility and and if that
doesn't it will be pushed to like early
2025 but I I I don't here's the
thing if people was upset this year from
the amount of qu uh the amount of games
that Xbox was able to throw out and they
just don't want to come out there and
admit that and they use everything under
the sun to attack Xbox Xbox x I don't
think you're ready for the future of the
brands I don't think you're ready for
this jelly I don't think you're ready
for this jelly I feel like cuz you know
was dancing tooo
booty not bootylicious Contin I feel
like PlayStation had a certain
opportunity add camera is Frozen for
some reason I just want to let you know
continue he did it on purpose no I
didn't I didn't I feel like PlayStation
like the little the the 4K thing that my
camera hooks up to my I think that's
messing up okay but um I think you're
going to start
seeing so many many games that are ready
in development that Microsoft's going to
have to internally delay games just so
they're not eating each other up okay
you know I think gears will probably be
ready early
2025 late
2025 but at that same time we're
probably G to seeing perfect Dart Fable
I think G is next year he's just talking
about 2024 as what all I'm just talking
about in terms of the amount of games
going to come out you're going to see
titles gears getting getting finished
but they have the outer worlds to
probably finished around the same time B
finishing around the same time and
they're gonna have to just naturally
internally you'll never hear it right
but they'll be like okay go go back in
the lab make sure this game is very
polished and come back in six months
because you might be ready but we ain't
ready yeah we can't and that's what
happens when you have a service right
when you have a service where you have
committed to day and date inside your
service you you don't want to can
cannibalize uh your earnings inside
there it's a beautiful problem to have
hell yeah you know PlayStation ain't got
that problem oh my God like cuz we don't
know what the hell happened in
that I think Wolverine hell no yes sir I
think either way we have at least an
early road map sometime in January I
think I think they say something in
January yeah I I think I heard Bungie
coming home I he I think that I think I
heard somebody paid too
much I'm putting it now I might have
been very up and down with the with this
game because of of what I expected it to
look
like but it I would expect a vow to be
nominated for game of the year next year
so you got a vow you got a vow coming
yes a vow is coming coming releasing
okay that part yeah Jesus what you do
I'm not like you guys I don't make
everything perverted so I'm saying K he
are you serious this guy here he's crazy
I know him I know him hope is that they
work they work to this Crescendo again
right so you start working from the
smaller games and then you make your way
you know to whatever like AOW and then
your hellblade right I think the
hellblade we talked about the power of
the just one right around awards time
and you know if hellblade is at game
then you probably won't leave that for
the fall you know comat better be better
crazy like we're talking now where you
know Starfield didn't get nominated once
if like two or three games get nominated
for game of the year next year from
Xbox we're talking here's the thing
we're talking from like this perspective
next year most likely we're going to see
vast majority of games going to Game
Pass from ABK you're gonna see early
talks of Call of Duty going into Game
Pass day and day you're gonna see a vow
Halo uh a vow hellblade maybe Oblivion
remakes to see a change hey hey how how
much you want to bet there would be like
Oblivion remake and a Fallout 3 let's
let's hypothetically say they both come
out next year and Jeff key ironically
that year makes it a a a remake
category that' be funny but then we we
have Clockwork what was the
midnight I think they little ways away
the
midnight the Clockwork one what's it
called Clockwork Revolution from NX I I
think that's 2026 yo I I honestly think
they will switch you know how when a lot
of these dudes was uh Xbox dudes and
then the PlayStation 4 taking off and
they was like they started making
PlayStation channels like over here oh
man that's what you GNA see you GNA see
oh I'm a triple
changer here's my
thing I got get my bars off especially
especially because of the pandemic I
feel like for the most part Xbox has
like been in a defensive position they
just taken the hits over and over again
and and now Sony's like like it's like
you you got those uh those boxing gloves
on
son going deep into later rounds later
rounds they got and Microsoft just
stands up cracks to the next like oh
it's hilarious hilarious yeah we I ain't
hear no bell all you going to see is
play if be like is that Bell no you got
three minutes to get this
wor these scenarios people have pain I
love it yeah look I think 2024 what M
booty said was pretty accurate ARA Tara
Bor talking about I think people
forgetting about um even though people
don't consider it but it's a huge
franchise on PC is M Microsoft flight
simulator the new one going to be there
you know if they're able to which I
think we'll get as far as the ABK Call
of Duty Diablo will be in there you know
what I'm saying as far as as the um I
know they got a new expansion or
something coming up all of that should
line up with with Game Pass and then
hopefully hellblade at the late of the
year a v we got to see you know what I'm
saying cuz I know that the vision has
switched like two times from what I
heard from one time from this vast or
we're going to be a Skyrim like
experience to oh you know what let's get
back to what we do which is kind of like
that controlled out of Worlds and I do
for some reason I just feel like a out
of Worlds remember we had obsidian on we
had them on for the murder at M aronal
after that they were already working on
out of Worlds 2 then remember we got the
trailer earlier for some reason Worlds 2
is early 2025 I think Auto Worlds 2 is
more sooner than a lot of people think
but we're g to see what's going on with
that but yeah they got they got a big
lineup and stuff we don't even know
about even talk about Indiana Jones
there's a lot of ips we still don't even
know about what's up you know what's
going to be funny I'm willing to bet you
that the next few years people were
complaining star a get nominated for
game of the year will bet the next the
next like three years is going to be an
Xbox nomination in that category every
year we going see I know GT I already
told you when I put out the tweet I said
y'all GNA have to nominate us for
everything cuz we gonna own
everything like it don't matter what
y'all do it's inevitable y'all can hate
all y like y GNA be on this side
regardless we going to buy the hotel it
I can't one more patreon unless you got
more bars for that one we good Jay
Boogie 327 happy Sunday Lords what was a
game this year that you wanted to be
good but just missed the mark Rocky C
Rocky City seemed to Sure Fire hit to me
but poor optimization at launch along
with epic games exclusive tag hurt this
one I don't think PlayStation 5 Gamers
even talked about this one when it came
to console real dude bro energy with all
the Vibes of payday and left for dead
anyway how you enjoy hope you enjoy the
holidays and hope you guys feelish out
strong thank you IL blessings you and
yours salute J Boogie so uh what game
came out this year go first yes that Mr
I I have two my first one is hogwart's
Legacy I I enjoyed what I played on it
but I expected more of like like the
first couple Movie experience where like
the classes are being judged you're
getting points you have to win for your
class like I expected more of that now I
do think the foundation they have there
is good enough to go into that but I
didn't get what I initially expected
from a Harry Potter game uh the second
one's Final Fantasy 16 I wanted that to
be good everything in me wanted that to
be good but then everything me he's like
they already let you down too many times
man what you do it like you know 15 was
a step in the right direction for the
franchise but I had to lived through the
atrocity not as Final Fantasy 13 for
like 10 years so you know they they like
at this point the past 10 years they're
like they're like one and four with me
right now cuz I do consider a remake A W
yeah of of course of course no doubt Sol
what game missed the mark for you this
year yeah I'm going give two as well and
it's obviously red fall is oh God yeah
it's mine right there really really
missed the mark especially again after
us having played that game and and being
feeling good about what we saw and
having the final product not be that
yeah good was very very very
disappointing and the other one was for
spoken
um
third person action adventure game where
was that laugh during the during the I
he that laugh in he red forward n cuz
you know what everybody forgot that they
buried that body and you didn't well
they really buried that body that that
Dev Studio does not exist anymore
exactly um but for spoken for me I I'm
always of the mind that I want to see a
game and play a game before I make my
assessment no matter what else anybody
else is saying mhm and and you know
though the the the the dialogue sounded
cringy I was like yo it's a third person
action game a you know a character from
New York a female let's see where they
take this world let's see what this is I
was excited to see what it could be and
when I got my hands on it I'm like oh
man they just it was just cookie cutter
and the dialogue was really that bad the
fact once again I had if you haven't
noticed I have an issue with people you
know characters that are from New York
not sounding sound like New York
like miles yeah um so that was another
big you know sticking point for me with
this game it was just disappointing
because I was like damn they they really
just dropped the ball all the way around
in this game some people really like it
yeah I you know when it's $5 I'll I'll
give it a shot yo not to$ damn Super
Black Friday jump off for S continue so
those two what was your uh game that
missed the mark for you I got three of
them okay let's go okay uh that son sonc
All
Stars I just felt that you just didn't
have to come out that time um you didn't
care about your product um y'all are
really thinking he's Sonic from 86 and
he's not know like let's let's really
assess him for who he is you know he
still got a name let's have some respect
he ain't Manny Pacquiao from back in the
days this is yeah this is exhibition
Manny Pacquiao you understand what I'm
saying you got to put him in a service
you got to help him along
di in hands you know exactly he's got to
put him to fight Jake
Paul and you you putting him out there
going against the champ like against
Mario Mario said up you back again
herball knock out cold um Spider-Man wow
I did my second play
through and I'm like d man like the
first one was definitely my game of the
year um this one in my heart I wanted to
be my game of the year cuz of how I feel
about the character um it's
not you know it's not the
story um the things that are done I'm
just seeing a destruction of characters
and I'm just appalled at it and I just
didn't think that some of this stuff
will permeate our uh gaming space uh you
know it made me walk away from comic
books so and it's in our gaming space at
this moment right now there a lot of
things that's transpiring and I don't I
didn't like the the where the story went
I purchased it I played it I played it
again and I just really the first time I
was just so exhilarated in the ride and
what I was doing and stuff was happening
and then when I go back and I play it
and I start looking at it I'm like damn
they this is not necessary but um it's a
disappointment it's not a fail for me
right right yeah this is what he said we
that you wanted to be good but just miss
the mark for you and I want to redfall
just to talk just you know yeah cuz I
didn't know what redfall was was nobody
did and then you always said that yeah
you always said that they they made us
like somebody that we didn't know like
you know he he's he's fresh he's hot
he's cool and I was like but what did
you do yeah you don't know either I
think mine's pretty much the same ones
that you said obviously red fall for
reasons it just wasn't representative of
what we played that highend PC version
of what we played that play the same
when we
got we only got
293 likes
people watching get the likes up please
out here we got we Save ad dancing
yesterday got get the likes up I bet you
if Alex isn't here giving his thigh slap
you guys like the video the second like
I said for spoken yeah I I was I
remember playing the demo and I'm like I
like the potential of it the you know
the move and how she's but I I just
could not dis I disconnected with that
voice I just like you said the New York
thing is real passionate for me me if
you say you from New York come on like I
I just wasn't feeling that and the third
one I'm going piss everybody off but
it's just me starf tears of the Kingdom
okay tears of the Kingdom like I am such
a breath of the wild Fanboy y'all know
how hard I go for it and I dropped tears
of the Kingdom pretty quickly like how
fast I gave it like a good eight 6 to8
hours um look the creativity of the
sandbox I get absolutely outstanding I'm
not going to take that away but um it
just I'm like I'm still here it's the
same thing to me and you just remixed an
album in a way to me you know what I'm
saying so it just didn't connect with me
I know people love it I'm not saying
it's a terrible game it just it just
didn't connect with me so I don't have
that oh my God it's a 10 too the thing
yeah I really loved breath of the wild I
think you know tears of the Kingdom uh
gave you know scenarios that can't
happen breath of the wild but I really
felt like it was just a reskin breath of
the wild that's how I felt it's like I'm
sitting here playing I'm going all these
regions I think I've said this all on
the it just felt like breath of the wild
2.0 I go to this region do whatever I'm
supposed to do there I got a champion
time to go to the next one time to go to
the next one that's lit it felt like
everything they wanted to do in the
first one and now they had have more
time but that's just me wait I'm sorry s
you going to say no no no it kind of
makes sense is what some people feel
like is like it's like it's it's what
breath of the wild should have been if
they took another 5 years with it or
whatever develop cycle exactly but
anyway let me go on take that Don
Nintendo oh now he coming at you he said
now he really loves breath of the wild
adct stop cing no no first off I've
never said I didn't like breath of the
wild I said it was the worst Zelda I
enjoyed breath of the wild but in terms
of Zelda and comparing it to its
predecessors it always fell short so if
you're going to quote me Nintendo d
talking quot quote me correctly yeah
your issues
always damn not the back that you come
your issues was always the dungeons you
love the game and I even said in tear of
the Kingdom they did better dungeons but
they was still lacking chill a Ron Miss
[__] didn't want to be the creepy dude
hanging out the Elementary School
playing look I was a creepy dude with
breath of the wild you know it's not the
same thing like people saying that's the
same thing it it's not the same thing
Fallout four is a fantastic action
shooter pom pom kind of game but it's a
bad Fallout game final fantasy 16 is a
great action adventure hit a couple
buttons Mo dodging stuff but it's a bad
Final Fantasy game there can be both
scenarios and both can be right oh t let
me just let meop he he go super chat you
all day now never going to stop but any
we got to move cuz we didn't get to show
we thought always going to be a quick
show but look where we
at look where we at people are very
passionate today uh last week's poll
results are in the people have spoken to
the question with the recent
announcement of the nominees at the game
awards which do you think would benefit
the show the most the winner of the
farway high
heo yah still got to get rid of that
Xbox Tax
Group at
38% coming in that second and a razor
close 33% was um hire committees who
play specific genre titles that have
input on the nominees third place 19%
was flesh out the category so they are
not all lumped together and in last
place at only 8% was let the devs accept
the awards on screen King they feel the
Xbox tax is real your thoughts it is
real you have these people out here
trying to debunk something that they
know they're lying about like you know
maybe you yourself don't have a Xbox
bias but your people that's standing
right next to you do and it's um it's
it's a collusion thing it's it's a buddy
system it's an unspoken word like right
now I remember when Xbox was cool right
like oh you got Xbox I'm going to play
my Xbox 360 yeah 360 it was cool do bro
stuff oh you gonna play Call of Duty
yeah Xbox Halo all right so oh you play
Playstation what's up with you like and
then if you say you got Nintendo they
definitely call you a little kid like I
don't matter how old you are where you
at with it you pull out your switch
dudes is like come on my man like no
matter what I don't care who where they
they number one nobody cares that they
looked at as kids stuff right now it's
cool you know for the PlayStation stuff
so it's like these iPhone dudes and you
know uh Sams Android
guys yo this these iPhone dudes is
weirdos um shout out to sales um you my
peoples you remember what you said um
but the the fact of the matter is it's
all going to change Xbox is going to be
cool again because you going to bend the
knee CU you ain't got noo choice and you
want to make money you going to have to
change your channel to formul why they
got to change their whole YouTube
channel you know you all you do right
now that's on the PlayStation Channel
y'all are worried to death right now y
saw that bankruptcy stuff y'all are
worried to death because if they go down
you go
down they're going to switch to Nintendo
channels oh man y got highend PCS I
cannot anyway we are good so I got to
ask you question I know your time is
limited today so I got to be respectful
um so what we want to do we want to do
the stars uh the N of the old or should
we just jump into let's jump straight
into the uh the round thing okay we yeah
we going to do CR your lord then let me
get these super chats super chats how
many we got live uh a couple couple let
just make a real
quick we got uh BT Maverick 707 $5 Super
Chat red dragon more like wed wagon
never never seen Xbox uh own as much
real estate in one person's head other
than
Jay there we got JD gamer $20 Super Chat
I clipped the guy returning his PS5 and
and and unprompted and he said he was
returning it because Xbox has better
games Xbox has better graphics seven he
doesn't have to worry about Xbox
overheating PS fans saw this and they're
mad out
here this is true I mean and you caught
that you know that unicorn that was
running through the store that had all
that to say I don't know if he was a
plant I don't know could have been a
plant could have been a plant could have
his
cousin could have been a K&N
affiliate he could be on the
payroll then we got JD gamer again $5
Super Chat PS fans are watching Xbox
getting first party game after game
after game after game and many of them
are looking like bangers while all
PlayStation is getting it games as a
service game
yeah popey's
biscuits half y'all got that y had a
dozen of donuts and then somebody came
and took
half messy we got JD gamer again $5 chat
PS fans over over there and and can't
keep Xbox out of their mouth because
they're Green With Envy oh my God they
feel the Wind of Change and they're sac
and they're scarred not sacred
scarred then we have Justin
buam VR should count more as a console
than the portal that is correct yeah
because it cost the same prices to
C then we have the professor with the $5
Super Chat wifey asked me how long this
IOP run on Sunday I told her five hours
and she says five hours how the hell do
they talk so long and me I just
shrugg my wife says the same thing she's
like how are y you talk about women
gossiping y she coming that's crazy she
coming at us hey hey what you want what
you want what you want what you I love
that's right absolutely absolutely then
we got JD gamer $10 Super Chat in the
next 24 months you're going to see
PlayStation fans go through it all the
stages of grief as PlayStation Falls of
Grace expect denial this can't be
happening anger why did this happen who
is to blame next $10 super chat again JD
gamer JD more bargaining make this not
happen and I will and next and I will
dot dot dot then you have depression I
can't bear this I'm too sad to do
anything then you have acceptance I
acknowledge that this has happened and I
cannot
change JD what's going on man he can't
wait he he has a particular person that
he's after okay okay this that's what
this is got to be what else we got JD
once again rounding everything out yes
$5 super chat right now they're in
denial they're blaming Xbox for
PlayStation's fall soon and acceptance
will be too hard for many of them to
Bear but you can't save
Kong thank you Kong will die thank you
for season one of console war appreciate
that looking for season two you know
what I'm saying ridx make we should
definitely make a reality show out of
this yeah this is this is this is
comedy we all caught up yes sir all
right so before before we actually get
into Crown your lord quick question as
we do want to jump it off this is what
everyone's talking about as far as the
rumors the rumors is that Xbox will have
a presence at the game awards so before
we get into it ask real quickly you know
you know some people are talking gears
you know what I'm saying there's been
other rumors maybe Indiana Jones maybe
some other IP something we don't know so
what are your thoughts if Xbox is going
to have a presence start what you saw
what do you think they show H at the
game awards at the KE
Le oh man maybe it is Indiana Jones I
really do think that is their that's the
closest thing besides hellblade that
they have to that just code of Just One
energy and Indiana Jones is that thing
where I mean if Indiana Jones is that
thing where it's not a license that's
super popular anymore but if you show me
a game that exhibits those sort of arted
Laura Croft type uh sort of character
traits and it has that feeling of a
blockbuster it'll resonate um I don't
think they come come back with hellblade
unless it is com unless it is
specifically Combat gameplay and it is
the greatest combat
you I don't think they come back with
help another thing I gota be
surprised on a on a on a third party
sort of uh
thing if they do come if
if if Atlas comes out wait you coming
you coming home you coming home
officially officially announces you
coming home baby you coming home the
next Persona I believe we will know if
it's on Xbox or Not by the end of night
I don't think it'll be there sa is
coming home I believe I believe if they
just a quick little teaser announcement
with with all the platforms I believe
we'll know cuz I think that'll be big
for Xbox fans that'll be that'll be a
huge thing itself so how one way or the
other we will know the street how go
at yeah I like that I didn't say it was
going to be there I said one way or
another will know one way another fair
enough Fair the adct before we start
crying your lord the thoughts on you
know the rumors of Xbox having a
presence may show a game we haven't seen
or something not announced you know
rumors I think my man risky for the
biscuit is outside talking again six
heavy in the street and cold and all
these guys I'm hearing you know um
Indiana Jones potentially any new IP
what you what you think
happening I think as much as I would
like to see gears because I I'm a I'm a
fan of the direction they wouldn't gears
five I know I'm like one of the only
people that liked the direction that
five went I would love to finally get to
get my hands on gear six and you know
see how that concludes yeah I don't
think it's going to be there like cuz to
me there's always there's always small
leaks of something up into a big
announcement and we have almost heard
nothing about gears now that that could
be you know Coalition tighten up the SE
seat but in my experience and I think we
can all agree here Xbox has never been
the greatest at maintaining their
secrets true
yeah if it showed up that' be great I
would love it you know I think you know
Tod Howard did say we're going to be
seeing uh you know more on Indiana Jones
next year so you know that's a
possibility I think you know we could
also see a hellblade gameplay reveal
which I don't think that's plausible but
I think that is possible um or it could
be just a random new IP that no one
knows about I I know that they're
working with more Japanese oriented
developers we might see like an
exclusive jrpg pop up on the brand okay
you know I think m
is going to save a lot of their big
stuff like like fresh reveals for war
stuff like this and like people are
saying well you know we might see
hellblade the reason I don't think we're
going to see that is because I think
they're saving that for a direct yeah I
wish you I don't I don't if I see it I'm
gon be disappointed what if a combat
fire they sure that's that's still cool
you should have saved it for you so you
a king don't go give him nothing yeah
don't don't give them nothing take from
them everything okay I see what I see
what you're doing for it's cool you know
but but if scory Enix comes on that
stage and says Final Fantasy 7 remakes
coming Xbox that is different okay I do
think we'll see a boers gate Shadow drop
though I agree with you gay
pass that would be good to me break the
internet to
me there's no reason to make this
announcement live to do a shadow
draw because I feel like you could
literally just announce it's coming out
that day sent n to fix it and then you
going to take the Game Pass that's how
it went down like to to me why would you
go out and wait till you get on stage
just to announc it's coming out part of
me thinks there will be a Game Pass
announcement with the announcement but
it's hard to tell on that terms you know
D that that would be a very expensive
deal for Microsoft I don't know if
they're willing to spend that kind of
money right now that's a lot I do think
that after the ABK deal concluded the
this these going out getting these type
of games I think that's a wrap like they
not doing that no more they might do it
a couple more times for like the show
anything that makes PlayStation look bad
but but as far as like people say they
need to get more third party like that's
the reason they're buying these
Publishers they don't want to rely on
other people because when you buy triaa
products from these companies talking
hundreds of millions of dollars
sometimes to get them yeah and I know JD
gamer is like a big Advocate on them
like securing GTA
6 it's not happening
yeah
May the internet hold on hold on hold on
hold on stop the CH we got to we got to
send our love kid Smo is in the chat man
we we heard about y condolences brother
you know with the family and everything
good to see you up in here salute salute
kiss move the best spot man much love
brother we miss you I hope you doing
okay to you that's the first time I've
seen him in the chat a couple weeks good
to see your face man for real for real
I'm sorry I just had to shout out kid
yeah so that that's pretty much my thing
I I think the best we'll see is a gear
six the middle uh the middle ground
we'll see is like a is a a hell not a
hellblade is like an Indiana Jones
announcement and the bare minimum we'll
see is like Game Pass announcement and a
hellblade to combat
reveal and what's funny is like even the
bare minimum that's still a lot
considering it's not your show uh I
think at this point you know with
Microsoft it because they have so many
studios so many unannounced stuff we
don't know what ABK is working on facts
uh there's so many studios could be
working on something like that we don't
know what that's the greatest thing
right now about being in the Xbox
ecosystem is the is the unknown Journey
because we have no clue what they're
doing throwing his hoodie on why why you
getting all gangster now what what
what's going on it's very aggressive
energy for me right now what's going on
back to you K what what do you think one
of the rumors is at this game awards Man
Xbox I think
um they going to be the villains you
think they are what they going to do
what they going to do now I think now
the S Barn in charge of situations
[Music]
mhm she going to want make a splash in
her in her way she going she want to she
want to show you the presence of you
know Xbox okay I'm I'mma tell you man
never mess with a woman's scor
bro never never never like y'all didn't
give us our invite to the Game of the
Year Awards so what we going to do what
we gonna
do we gonna put all our propaganda all
up in this
place what's the propaganda IND Jones is
going to show up oh wow okay okay Gars
is going to show up we getting two drops
bolders Gates going to Game Pass we
getting three drops listen listen listen
Boulder Gates going to Game Pass they're
gonna be the Talk of the Town they're
gonna shut it down and then then
Boulders gate is going to win game is
going to win game of the year so you
going to have Game of the Year inside
Game Pass oh so we already doing I
already know what your vote is at at the
top yeah exactly so so that's going to
be inside Game Pass okay what's funny
they're going to announce that bers
Gates on Xbox before it's announced at
one game so so the marketing King going
to be play the game of the year on Xbox
when that game pass play the game don't
throw
your I like your hands like that like
that's how going down the Game of the
Year Edition on XO they going say Game
of the Year Edition before they announce
the
it's they going come with the sticker
out they going come outside with the
sticker Phil going walk in with the
sticker let you know exactly what it is
it is what it is so it's the production
pipeline going to say game the year
before they announce listen listen
listen and and the further lean on my
conspiracy because a lot of you dudes
like y'all don't y y' Xbox dudes are so
beat down y' don't dream y'all have no
dreams y'all have no dream y scared to
dream like I don't know what Xbox is do
best case scenario they uh they say
hi n yo and then and then a couple of
weeks later yeah you gonna
get an
announcement lant Studios is purchased
by oh my and we going to acquire them so
so so so now we are the home we actually
won game of the
year it's actually so you going to brw
force the Game of the Year by then
listen listen Phil going to come out and
accept the award on of stud he can come
out hold up hold up hold up hold up time
out time out imagine how beastly that
would be if they announc Boulders gate
one game of the year and Phil shows up
on that stage I bet you guys are
wondering why I'm
here he said he said you didn't predict
that did it
one way or another and he
say I would like to thank everybody that
voted for
us and he G to do that 20 hour speech
that you might as well come with an Xbox
ta imagine him leaving imagine him
leaving and he's like and I just got one
last thing to say if you can't beat him
buy him and who did that for you who did
that all you going to hear is he's
stupid when walks out money money money
not the Shad back he going to come with
the Shad
back everybody got a price a million
doll
milon yo you stupid and when it happens
and when it happens run back to me and
say damn King how the hell you know that
because I'm telling you who did that for
you y'all been messing with somebody
with real cash real cash y'all didn't
think ABK was going to happen he threw
70 billions on the table he it wasn't no
debit card it wasn't no
damned
card it was pay he said put the duffel
packs on the table and ABK get in the
Box y'all dudes overpaid for
Bungie and man got fired and you did it
on a finance I cannot not the and then
and then and then the documents Le king
and you find out the reason they
overpaid for Bungie is cuz Microsoft was
bidding against I know right
go shook like I can just see I can see
Phil I can see Phil and young old just
sit in room like it's like that one
thing where they sitting in the the uh
the bidding room and he's like bid one
more time he's going to bid again do you
want you want him paying 50 million or
100 million one more time magical
scenarios no you you know why I say they
they can beat the whole
villain Microsoft just did some wild
stuff the other day what they do the uh
the the opening eye oh to open their eye
that the Sam yeah all right so y want to
boot them out all right come over here
we got to drop for you and send out the
mass email let everybody know watch out
for everybody everybody had to sit there
and contemplate I don't really want to
work here no
more bring her back that that was saa's
gangster right there cuz he was like cuz
the stock price dropped immediately and
then when he said that it's
Skyrocket yeah that was a bu going back
right czy at that part it's like y'all
going to keep disrespecting us we got to
do what we got to do okay all right I
see what it
is by the way I shout out shout out to
the good friends of elado if you see me
a little crispier you know what I'm
saying it's that new face cam Pro check
it out y'all you know what I'm saying
shout out to our good friends I got
sending this over right quick and they
they told me call you got step the
camera game up shout out toon step the
game up oh yeah cuz I noticed your
camera wasn't doing the wo yeah yeah you
know I'm saying we wasn't in 480i
anymore oh okay okay they D us y Elgato
elato it's called iron Lords podcast
it's three it's three other members and
they they definitely like the way the
situation you see the shirt they left
they left us on Red King they left us on
red this and tag Elgato on Twitter El
face cam Pro we working on it baby work
on this and tag them and us on Twitter
facts and then hash left them on and and
I know y'all saw the email because it
said right at
the up we working on we working but look
real quick I'm white is it oh man don't
do that don't do that mess it up the bag
don't fumble the bag we ain't get it yet
so my my thing is um yeah I I if I had
to guess man I mean it is time for in a
way it is time for Gears to coalition to
kind of see what they doing so you know
I wouldn't be surprised can't imagine
what that game's going to look like they
were one of the only people besides epic
that can make that use that engine
Coalition know how to make that ue5 sing
I got mad at them for not promoting um
hivebusters enough Hive Busters am that
showed me what series X could do and I'm
like we want to see more of that I mean
it's possible um I think Indiana Jones
kind of makes sense too yeah because
Indiana Jones is like we heard from Todd
he said that yo we're going to you're
going to hear from us soon it kind of
makes sense with the whole key Le movie
Indie plus machine Gams you know
whatever they do it it's a straight bang
plus I want to know if it's first person
third person a mix of both whatever that
type of energy is and then um I'm going
go out on a Lim to something crazy
remember the leak that was like um the
the leak that what everybody in zenax
was working on and I saw disigned three
on that list dis showed up there you
would hear me scream like a fany if Jo
did Sonic show up hey
heyy good okay sorry I think because
they did confirm that death Loop and
dishonor in the Universe I I think
you'll be playing with corvo and Cole
will be in the same
game my goodness that would be sick and
to me I'm one of the few that believe
that that list for the most part is
accurate just late I just feel like
everything's kind of behind with
production screwed a lot that pmic I if
you got death in my opinion if you have
death Loop 3 on your list dishonor three
on your list you had a team teams agreed
creatively we want to make this
yeah so if it was on the list I can't
see all of a sudden now it's off the
list we're not going to do it the only
thing I can see is oh it just got pushed
back because now we just remember ghost
wide Tokyo was on that list ghost wide
Tokyo 2 was on that list death Loop was
on all those games came out and there's
a perfect way to do this too Cog imagine
like them doing like a a Cole trailer
and you you know it's giving like huge
death death Loop two Vibes and then you
just in a random scene the next scene
you see that ask at
cor and then they should cuz a lot of
people don't know like during the events
of of Dishonored one and two Co is stuck
in that Loop over and over again and at
the end obviously you break the loop so
like we don't know what happens after
that after that yeah we'll see but yeah
I'm getting ready see what's going on
but now it's time to do what we do kill
SOL at some point a try Die Trying give
me a second let me try to share this
screen let's get this perk
you want me to share just I should be I
got to get good at this I got to get
good at this so give me a second if you
got Sony Mouse you should be good at
Shar oh man if you share if you share it
won't show us at the bottom of your
screen I know I know it's going it's
going to be the thing but it's it's all
good let me know if the realm did you
see did you see what Young dreads posted
on his
Twitter he's got a crying gem meme go a
little
animation gift crying Jim can y'all see
the um joint yet on the screen let me
know y'all can see him he yeah I see it
yes okay cool cool that's the best
Esports game I see that all right cool
oh actually you want let me get you want
me get the super chats real quick yeah
get the super chats get the Super Chat
while we cooking up you know what I'm
saying you know I'm
saying yeah he's dead wrong he's getting
his animation on right now yeah he get
his animation cooking we got Michael
Mooney 5 pound Super Chat what if the
embracer play offs mean Perfect Dark has
something to show I don't think that's
what it means I think that's me that's
cool then we got Jay rbert $20 Super
Chat I supposed to believe Xbox is
leaving the industry in 2027 after all
the Acquisitions on the PlayStation side
canceled games closing Studios execs
getting fired fudging the numbers no
road map Etc the PlayStation Community
is down bad oh JD the season one JD you
know what's up you good yeah we got blue
with the $2 Super Chat thank you Jim for
bringing the PlayStation
apocalypse yeah he was the
Messiah then we got here the Messiah the
other way around yeah yeah the Messiah
of the
Apocalypse then we got then we got no
more Oscar for $2 Super Chat face cam
Pro making cogs beef more
clear Elgato beefy out here real beefy
real real beefy
situation we are caught up all right
y'all know what it is Crown your lord
returns where we look at all the
nominees from the game awards and we try
desperately to defeat Lord Sovereign who
has dethroned us every damn year minus
one for
yourself King has one one kinging dou
tied up only pathetic say some weird
stuff just some weird stuff just I was
going to say something crazy but I'm Let
It Go but uh yeah it is time so we gonna
get these categories popping let's start
off with best Esports game for the game
that has delivered the best overall
Esports we don't normally cover these
games yeah Esports game we we've done in
the past as a general game thing yeah
it's a category so yeah the best orts
you know inclusive of tournaments
community support and content updates
irrespective of genre or platform
choices all Counter Strike 2 Dota 2
League of Legends pubg mobile mobile or
valerin what are we doing Lawrence who's
who's jumping they vote out first
Sovereign goes first and sees the champ
oh that's how I go to Champ don't the CH
get to go oh it's up there it's up there
whatever you want to do so what yall
doing I'm going go with League going
with League of Legends All right we
going League um addict are you waiting
to for others to vote or are you putting
your hat in the ring hold no I'm uh I'm
putting on my uh I'm writing everyone oh
you writing the vote down okay all right
so s s we what I want to do this year is
go you think going to want to go what
you want like what would you vote if you
didn't go what you think cuz I want to
see yo if you would just stuck to your
gut you would have won instead with my
heart I would say like I mean they put a
two after Counter Strike so that that
should have been like this huge huge
thing and it's good but it is they they
just added They just added quality life
stuff to The Counter Strike it's not
like transformative certain things that
are very different but uh yeah in my
heart of hearts Counter-Strike 2 would
have been it but I think it's league
league is just continue to
just well I'm jumping my AFK nobody else
everybody scared to vote I'm okay
everybody playing a strategic game right
now no no mine is League of Legends and
my my heart would have been pubg mobile
I knew you was going to say that yep I
got League same here so everyone's
voting League adct you voted League uh
I'm voting uh valerant o setting off the
devant all right all right you got
everything in an ready to move on so you
are League everyone's League everyone's
League yes all right moving on we're
going to skip we're not doing the
content creator of the year we will be
moving on from that all right here we go
now we get spicy most anticipated game
recognizing an announced game that is
demonstrably Illustrated potential to
push the game medium forward we got
Final Fantasy 7 rebirth Hades 2 like a
dragon infinite wealth Star Wars Outlaws
and Tekken
8 what are we doing who jumping out the
window that's a dope that's a dope list
a dope with Final Fantasy rebirth going
for that Sony bag sure
win I see what we doing I see what we
doing see how that yo not not not after
announc it's coming out for Xbox
boo yeah I'm I'm with King ff7 rebirth
in my heart is Hades too but ff7 rebirth
is going wi this in my heart is uh Star
Wars Outlaws antic what we doing um keep
going I'm right you you do yours I'm
still doing damn my heart you know my
heart is Tekken damn and infinite well
I'm messed up cuz those are two of my
joints but I know what that Final
Fantasy do that joint had to and then oh
they definitely Final Fantasy he was at
the key Le yeah yeah he is definitely F
they showed him off over there he had
the exclusive
yeah yeah I know what you're doing I
know what's going on I ain't gonna play
with my heart on this one so final fanty
what you got uh
adct uh Final Fantasy all right you G
have to go first with one of these
because I know what you doing no I I'm
I'm trying to do the yeah so you can go
first on this since you're trying to do
the thing do the thing that do the thing
so B I know what he do best adaptation
I'm really not trying to do anything
Ming with you I'm starting trouble what
I'm instigating recognizing outstanding
creative work that faithfully and
authentically adapts a video game to
another entertainment medium the choices
are Castlevania nocturn Grand
Turismo The Last of Us Super Mario
Brothers movie or Twisted Metal strong
category best
adaptation Anthony Mackey strikes again
oh going with Twisted you going with
Twisted hell no I'm not going with that
hell no Twisted I said I said he he he
strikes again he mess something up again
let's get Adda here first oh okay let
add go mine's Mario oh all right so
I'mma jump in early what's your heart my
heart is Mario I'm gonna go last for
straight out the rip that's what I'm I'm
going last for straight out the rip it's
it's the one thing that is the most
objectively overall liked I would say so
it's Last of Us in my heart I would like
it to be Castlevania nocturn but but I
think last of us is I love cat last of
us as well but um I think that's going
to win yeah last of us okay um I go with
Last of Us and in my heart I wanted
Super Mario yeah salute I think we all
got that I you all
good yes
um I I I go keep going because I just
like I I got behind the eightball from
the start oh okay now I got you but you
still going to do the with your heart is
that more work for you that it's fine
it's just I have to catch up okay okay
all right so I I'll stop messing with
you and I'll do regular stuff all right
best multiplayer for outstanding online
multiplayer gameplay and design
including Co-op and massively
multiplayer experiences irrespective of
game genre or platform choices are
balers Gate
3 Diablo
4 party animals Street Fighter 6
solve Super Mario Brothers wonder who is
coming away with this multiplayer very
stacked very stacked Diablo I'm going to
go with Diablo Diablo um my heart would
want it to be uh Street
Fighter got to get that
kid because I don't think Diablo would
anything else anyway this is this
Diablo's only shot this Diablo's only
shot I would say it's I find it it's
so it's I have not seen I have not seen
a fighting game in this category I don't
I mean show of like smash so for it to
come make it into this category it kind
of feels like it was highly voted for it
so I'm going to go Street Fighter oh I
real quick real quick just I'm almost
caught up okay King well what was your
um your heart for the for the last one
was it was it Mario pubg wa you mean for
um the movie The my heart was Mario okay
Mar all right and what was yours C my
heart on uh what you call it um yeah no
I think it was it was both last yeah
okay we're good all right cool all right
um all right most MTI player so you got
this you got this Street Fighter six uh
adct for multi catching up now you just
catching up now so for me I'm going to
go I'm a king man I don't see balers
gate winning this one they they go they
going to have they going to have their
day but I got this is the only shot I
think Diablo has Street Fighter 6 is
super
I feel sof it it technically should win
it too I'm go I'm going go Diablo I
think this the only shot they got to win
in
the that's why I'm back uh what you call
uh adct you said Diablo 4 yeah I said
Diablo 4 and what what is your uh my
heart is Street my heart is Street
Fighter though I do want Street Fighter
as a fighting game to win something and
what what was your Sol your heart with
both Street Fighter and Dia or Street
Fighter yeah pretty much I'm I'm almost
caught up
um
what we doing what we doing de I want to
say diablo but for some reason I feel
like Boulder gate coming with the dark
off stealing the vat all right all right
King you said Diablo right yes
sir okay and what was your thing my my
um my heart yeah my heart is um street
fighter fighter all right no doubt
moving on um no no I didn't I didn't I
thought you voted my fault my back back
back
okay I'm saying Diablo wait I thought
you said Boulders gate no I said I want
to say that oh so now so Diablo is your
pick yeah I I would want bers gate to
win but I feel like that's GNA be like
the only thing that they can win
anything on so they might get it just
because you know I think that out of
everything I don't know it might be
party animal probably think it could be
party animal too but I'm I'm going to go
Diablo enough now we got best sports in
racing the combined category here we
go two great things that go great
together go great together peanut butter
and jelly so for the again best
traditional and non-traditional Sports
and racing game EA Sports FC
f123 Forza Motorsport Hot Wheels
Unleashed turbocharge the crew motorfest
which the Lords have played like the
I'm going to jump right in if no one I'm
I'm going for on this one I'm going to
go for I'm going to I'm going to break
protocol see like this the only shot
they really got so I'm going to go for
that but it could be my heart probably
probably says could be EA Sports FC
because I know how big that is yeah but
um yeah I'm GNA go I'm going go f of
Motorsport adct so you can throw me down
there I'm going F and Motorsport as well
uh with my heart uh being the Hot Wheels
um I just think they're going to throw U
Microsoft a
bone they go you won an
award C the Xbox tax uh you know the tax
rebate
yeah here take this little Trophy and
shut up M I can't soft addict thoughts
my goodness uh I I'll go if you want
want me to yeah go ahead I think I'm
just going to I'm going to here's the
thing I don't care about this one and I
don't I don't know I don't think they'd
give it to Hot Wheels or for or the crew
I feel like it's between the the the
soccer
games and um I I'm gonna stay with the
crowd though I'm not I'm not leaving
this one I feel like I have done that in
the past left the crowd and lost because
one or two I could have just stayed with
you guys just and just had
I had had a straight equal but instead I
had a minus so right here I'm I'm saying
I want Forza to uh to win and my want
would be Forza to uh to win it too okay
okay
Sovereign very
quiet it's I'm gonna go with Forza I
think uh I think people really like the
crew motor Festival what it was
mimicking the Forza Horizon but um I
don't think people's F EA Sports is a
huge game but I don't think it was super
super well received right F1 feels Niche
Hot Wheels I think the the general
consensus is not as good as the first
one what about the crew it's Forza it's
Forza and in my heart is Forza too yeah
why not why not cuz I like the crew
motorest a lot but it is
remixing Horizon known
quantity you voted already right more
yeah so I got to upgrade his Forza for
got all right cool here we go best Sim
strategy focused on real time or term
based simulation irrespective of
platform this one's I'm sorry there I I
hate to say the this's [__] language
Advance Wars one and two City skylines
the Broken City skylines at launch
Company of Heroes Fire Emblem engage
Pikman 4 um I'm going to go with Fire
Emblem engaged okay and my heart uh
would have been uh City
skylines
okay Fire
Emblem
attic just I'll go last on this when I'm
catching
up just catch it up thing be interesting
I know Skyes well I have to type these
why you guys are
saying conven I'm go
I'm gonna go Pikman damn I was going to
do the same thing
okay I'm going Pikman I think Advanced
Wars also did but it was delayed so much
and it it came out and like not a whole
lot of fanfare it was Fanfare around
Pikmin even though Advanced Wars one and
two people seem to like it a
lot so Pikman Pikman and my heart would
be Advanced Wars Let man sof as the same
on that yeah I love Advanced Wars but I
first for some reason I don't feel it's
going to win and yeah Pikman for some
reason I think is going to win if I see
anything go to City skylines this whole
strategy thing need to be thrown out
into the bushes they don't know what
they talking about so you're just
copying uh solves yeah pretty
much and and when you think about what
was played and who's voting I would say
Pikman yes
um I think I'm going to
say I'm I'm gonna go with uh I'm gonna
go with the pink one one too I I do
think that Nintendo is gonna get some uh
a lot of rewards here but I would like
Fire Emblem to win I feel that I feel
that right we going to move on best
family game for the best uh game appropr
first for family play irrespective a
genre or platform Disney illusion Island
party animals Pikman 4 Sonic
Superstars or Super Mario wonder what we
doing
adct I'm going party
animals and I want I want I want Sonic
super stars to win just just to just for
everborn for everb just to go crazy we
want the critical claim yeah but I'm
going with party animals and then Sonic
is my heart okay okay I'll jump
in I just can't see nobody being Super
Mario Wonder in this category I just
can't see it I I mean once he starts
showing up he going to start sweeping
things so I'm going there my
heart is probably party animals not as
much as Sonic I love Sonic I don't know
I just like the fact that party animal
is getting some recognition I know it
ain't going to win though it is not
going to win cuz cuz I believe this
panel have not played it much to be
honest so I I actually disagree with
that
party animals like it it was like a
phenomenon for like a like a like a
little bit when it came out like I
actually feel like there's a lot of
people on the panel if anything they
have played party this fair enough
that's what I'm at where the rest to the
panel wait wait what's Lords doing king
um I'm going to go party animals and my
heart is Sega Sonic oh you going party
animals here is he's standing on
business all
right s Super Mario
and I think my heart would be party
animals as well i' like to see that get
Shine for real the little guy no doubt
no doubt we all caught up
adct uh no but I I'll catch up while
you're reading the next title Co best
fighting game and this is where lose
best game designed for head-to-head
combat God of rock Mortal Kombat
wow Nickelodean Allstar brawl to
pocket
bravery
or straight fighter six what we doing
too much what we doing finish him this
is old school this like a 90s battle
this is a battle this is a battle right
here y'all I realize what's going on we
haven't seen this since we kids yeah woo
comic this full who go first I'm saying
Street Fighter
but I want
MK1 one to win okay okay who jum think
MK could win that MK could win this too
yeah I think a lot more people when it
comes to the fighting community that
I've seen they they enjoy Street Fighter
more I'm jumping in to I'm wi addict I
think this is I think look I love Mortal
Kombat it's is all for me to go against
it best story in fighting but I think
Street Fighter did so much so
transformative the modes the
announcer yeah Street Fighter was that
game I I think it's overall package it's
it's it's tighter it's tighter I don't
think the competitive scene with Mortal
Kombat is just I don't know I'm just
going to go Street Fighter and my heart
though I do like Mortal Combat I'm same
thing I wanted to win for what they they
they bring to the narrative story but I
think Street Fighter is just too much a
behemoth this
year yeah Street Fighter 100% that and
that's my heart as well I think Mortal
Kombat
I think Mortal Kombat would have had
more of a chance if they hadn't had sort
of that negative press around the
monetization stuff later on yeah yeah um
and honestly I was a little disappointed
with the story like the story mode like
it just it happened too fast and at the
end of the day when I looked at I was
like oh it's endgame like I was like all
right I don't know I don't know Street
Fighter really was that package as goofy
as you know that story stuff was I
really do think Grandpa came back
Grandpa got to give it up King
David um I was going to say Mortal
Kombat
one because
of I just played Street Fighter 6 and
then we went and played Mortal Kombat
right after but it's not about me this
is about winning so street it's about
the W let's go get it's about Street
Fighter and then you know my heart would
have been Mortal Kombat all right
everybody's voted everybody's in so we
all pick the same thing yeah I think
everybody we are united on Street
Fighter no doubt watch we my heart my
heart was was Street Fighter as well
yeah so I was the only one with Street
Fighter Street Fighter yeah you know
it's funny watch all of us lose this one
and and I'm okay with that because as
long as we all lose none of us
win no doubt no doubt yo jff your
favorite addict is it sharing the screen
correctly because is it no your is fine
okay I can't I I'm not looking at the
screen on the YouTube channel King is it
seeing you seeing correct hold on you
you took up everything on mine um I you
took up my whole YouTube yeah cuz I'm
looking at it now and to see it saying
it's not I knew it something was not
right yeah okay see just show your
desktop yeah I'm nobody said that so I'm
like all right no I couldn't see
anything you took over my whole screen
my whole screen was you here let me let
me just do it yeah switch over cuz I'm
sitting everybody
quiet oh we've been telling you forever
you guys don't read oh cuz I could see
the chat took over my
F hold give me a second y to
the yo somebody got us some speaker yeah
it's me I'm I'm trying switch over if
you can I'll switch over again all right
there we go video game nomin I heard me
I was like hey that's me hi yeah the
chat been on cuz I couldn't even see the
chat something told me that's why I
pulled my phone I let me just make sure
everything is good well I saw it but I
thought it cuz sometimes like this
screen here is just old so I thought it
it just wasn't it wasn't
my co-host failed me they didn't tell me
I was out of pocket I was out here
Emperor was no clothes dancing to my own
music y'all let me
rock all right so start voting what
category was he we up to best fighting
what I'm not picking yeah yeah for the
whole time read the I can't when it was
full screen what what do you
want let me sign out because I already
voted so let me sign out sign out took
your C there we go now let me
share back
why you're not doing this every Sunday
get off that you're not doing this every
Sunday every Sunday she wanted to just
show her face screen one there we go
there you go good
Sharon yes all right let me double check
and make sure it's on the actual thing
best fighting you doing the
most all right we're good we're good
we're good I see I'm waiting for it to
catch it keep talking let me see let me
see yeah we good we good we good all
right cool there we go now the chat is
see there we go all right so we did best
fighting so we good moving on dudes was
sitting there we lost 100 people they I
don't even know what the hell they doing
over
there somebody need to tell them we
ain't seeing a damn
thing all right so can you guys see fine
now yeah I see the whole screen of what
K said talking to the chat not you oh
okay they was getting on us cuz we
wasn't reporting back what we saw I
can't see stuff all right let's go let's
go all right so um hit previous because
that's the order we go yeah
okay best RPG oo best game design with
Rich play experience customization
progression including massively
multiplayer experience balers Gate 3
Final Fantasy 16
lies of PE sea of
stars
or there can only be one you know what's
funny every time he stops like that
that's his heart every time that's my
heart that's my heart right there but
can it do it can it can it make it
happen in this Behemoth no my my best
RPG is SE of stars and Starfield is my
heart oh that he refuses to
Mo he a give Boulders gate no love Stars
I didn't play Boulders gate I can't sit
here and tell you something I didn't
play you know Sovereign is GNA sit here
he GNA go with you know with with
everybody in the world that's why he
wins that's what he wins he wins he wins
that way over a we slip with a ban I'll
go my my who I think's going to win B
gate but I want see a Stars
doing I don't want Boulders gate go
around sweeping
everything and that's it and at the end
of the day y'all didn't win nothing but
your win game of the year and Phil comes
out and pick up the
trophy and say thank you guys thank you
good
night King wants King wants bers gay to
and everything just so Phil can buy this
yo I want him to come out and say God
bless good night not the Russ
this is oh man it just sailed for me to
say this
but yeah but y'all know where I want to
go but it go say Starfield it Ain it
ain't happening they they they they they
showed me say with your chest starf they
they smacked me in the face with that g
a year joint so I already knew what type
of time it was they had their white
glove on so um yeah this is where
Boulders gate is going to make its
presentence this is where we might see
the same developer keep coming up on
stage C manad trophies Lia P I don't
know why you are here even though I love
you I don't know why I don't know why
16's there either um yeah we're not real
RPG mechanics um technically see Star
should have this so the heart is
Starfield but this is where larion gets
up on that stage and it starts to be
royal flush time so that's where we at
What's Your Heart Starfield okay all day
Starfield I had a I I kind of figured
but I had to double check yeah you just
went rubing
[Music]
this everybody voted no not me not me oh
s chilling in the cut chilling I mean
it's balers it's
balers and my heart is C of stars as
well yeah I know y love see stars I know
y love see Star no doubt everybody's
good everybody voted G say plot twist
it's that would be insane that would be
insane if they be bers here that that's
why I'm going to tally to I'm going to
tell you who officially won it BL blah
but yo if you would have picked your
heart you would have won it let's go I
don't even like that I love the game
because it remind me so much of my uh
Super Nintendo best action adventure for
the best action adventure game combining
combat with traversal and puzzle solving
this is
stacked Allan Wake 2
debuting Marvel Spiderman 2 Insomniac in
the building
mhm Resident Evil 4 which I've not been
happy with but it's
here Star Wars Jedi Survivor making its
presents it's debut into the realm of
the Lords that tears of the Kingdom
Behemoth I'll go first what you doing
tears of the Kingdom um because they Dam
sh a win game Y and and my heart would
have been
Spider-Man action
Adventure who's this is that I I am
right there with King Tears of the
Kingdom tears of the kingdom is winning
this and my heart would be Allan Wake
to what you
doing
uh I think I'm going to
lose this
isal yeah I got to go to too cuz like
here's the thing if it wasn't the
transversal I would be 100% on Resident
Evil 4 or Jedi survive because to me
Star Wars Jedi is the ideal one for this
because it's got better combat than
tears of the kingdom and it's got really
good traversal too but we we know that
that Zelda attacks that Zelda
yeah I'm thinking link outside for me
this thing should
be Jedi Survivor re sport should get
their bag shout out to the team but I
know big link is outside once he starts
showing his
face I don't care who you are expect
that same Nintendo Dev to keep coming up
on
stage this is where he starts to make
his pres felt same votes let's move
on
uh oh and my my want for this would be
Resident Evil yeah my want is that
Survivor
okay and you your yours was tear too yep
yep moving on I know I'm just and then
uh and you said Jedi Survivor okay yeah
J was my heart but I think T is going to
win all right let's get it best action
game armored Core
6 Dead Island 2
ghost Runner
to uhoh high five Rush makes his
appearance first time on any list and
Remnant two which is supposed to be
fire best action G best game of the
action genre Focus part on combat I'm
jumping in since everybody scared oh no
I'm not I'm not I'm I'm this is where
the Xbox tax gets lifted I feel high far
Rush going to make his run he my man T
what's my man John johanes I want to see
you in your best suit when you accept
this Ward cuz you came in the realm of
the laws showed you love look this is a
stat category they don't this mean they
going to win so I am kind of voed with
my heart and my and what I think is
going to happen so put me down for both
adct high five rush I'm going in I got
um high-f five Rush is uh the best new
action game uh for me uh I would have
said the remnant but the remnant really
didn't stray too far remant 2 didn't
stray too far from the first one it's a
little bit minor stuff um I'm going to
go with my heart is armor core o because
I think armor call would have won for me
if high five Rush wasn't
here I think high five Rush made enough
of an impact on the the stands that's
out there that you know trying to save
Kong Xbox tax rebate yeah they're going
they're going this is where they're
going to try to fool you and make yall
think there's no Xbox tag see y'all won
y'all won
Forza rush but nothing was good enough
and gave it a again yeah but you know
Starfield wasn't just it wasn't the
thing
man not with the man oh man you know
what a you know what a dude trying to be
a hippie come on man come on man all
right all right so I'm going let you
picked for oh he a cut he a cut it's to
yeah I agree I think it's it's is high
five's moment high five Rush uh and my
heart too I think Remnant had a moment
there like Remnant was a big deal for a
minute um but I just think overall I
think you know this is this is the one
this is the exception to the to to the
tax rule the tax rule it just kind of
does feel like everybody kind of loved
this and was so excited the fact that it
was a a shadow drop so good both both
high five Rush adct your
votes I'm flipping it flipping Kings I
think armor core is getting it and and I
want high five rush to win cuz where
yeah here's the thing
like there there's a huge love y for
from software that's what AIT said in
the chat core six I haven't played it
myself but I've been told it's a
fantastic game it's got fantastic
gameplay a lot of customization as much
as I love high-fi rush I feel like
because of games like Elden ring and and
the quality of the studio people I feel
like high Rush is going to win other
categories where they can give this one
to
core all right let's
go best VR
[Music]
AR Grant vot S Horizon call of the
mountain King's favorite
Humanity Resident Evil Village VR mode
and
synaps what what y'all doing I want Cog
to go first ah I know you want me to go
first man got rid of his
psvr2 I know you want me to go first all
right I'm going to do this um
generally resent Evil games kind of win
this but I am going to go with what I
think is going to win which is I think
is the better game I think humanity is
the better game I'm going to go with
humanity and Resident Evil Village VR as
my heart
all right I'm going to go with Call of
the
mountain Sony Sony tax um because Sony
needs to win
something we got to save Kong save
listen they got to save Kong so that's
why it's two Sony games
here no King it's because Sony is only
one with VR on their side I'm going say
shut up that ain't true oh I see I like
this from you I like your thinking I
like your thinking yeah cuz it's not
going to be Gran Turismo um that's going
to win best movie
uh but n it's uh it's calling the
mountain and in my heart I would have
wished it for Resident
Evil it is a better game I'm I'm not
gonna sit there in cap I mean that game
looks phenomenal they doing hell yeah
okay
okay oh play first yeah I'm I'm copying
uh
CS based on reasons yeah I'm copying you
hilarious you are hilarious so what did
you sorry what did you pick I don't like
how yall trying to pay ATT this is what
he Pi this is what yeah I picked
Humanity I've got Humanity um you are
ridiculous there only two pure VR games
here yep the rest of the games are
pancake games pancake addon kind of
games facts I'm a keep it the buck I
think I think it's going to be Horizon
that wins it just because of just
because of that was the game when psvr2
came out everybody just got that whether
they liked it or not and it's just one
of those things that everybody played I
think the deserving
game gr t7 is is amazing in VR it I
think it's synaps should get it synaps
is good but I think I think uh I think
just the the the general populace will
prevail on this one and I think it's
call it a mountain yeah I mean you guys
agree strong argument on on voting so
we's see what happens we'll see what
happens best mobile
game the Lords of mobile Final Fantasy 7
ever crisis Hello Kitty island
adventure H Kai
starel Monster Hunter now or Terra nil
y'all going on first I want King to go
King to
go King and solve to
go see right now is a tossup between
Monster Hunter and Final Fantasy um
that's only because I'm ignorant to
everything else um so I'm going to go
with what I would think is the most
popular one in this monster hunter um
and I would say Final Fantasy is my
heart man
s it is honai star
rail okay okay what you got what you got
addic stop it um what was your your um
what was your your your heart soul I
don't I don't care for any I don't care
you hay star real
twice okay I'm going with uh Final
Fantasy Final Fantasy because I really
don't care about none of this stuff oh
man we played Final Fantasy Crisis at um
PA West adct M we saw it we good what's
funny is we didn't actually play it we
just saw we just watched it yeah that
that's enough that I don't care about
nothing else on here so I'm going to I'm
going to imitate
s my heart was to say Final Fantasy 7
but I'm trying to win I'm trying to win
I'm frauding and hwai I heard the too
much about so that's why I'm
frauding what's your want Final Fantasy
my want is final fantas I thought it
looked really good when we saw that P
West I was like oh this actually looks
really
good okay almost done I just have to
hold these things mhm all
right yeah B oh Best debut indie game
for the best debut game created by the
independ new independent Studio
cocoon
Dred Pizza Tower this started a lot of
drama yes venba or viewfinder Little
Indie
scene this I'm going to go with a cocon
and uh we because I know no better and
um a viewfinder is my heart cuz I don't
know any better bro K I'm right behind
you I'm going with cocon this is I might
get in trouble and lose this category
yeah but I'm going with my heart and my
vote is cocoon I I just love those are
the dudes that made um inside and what
you call it but it could be Vena it
could be a lot this this is a tough one
this a there's a lot of little cool
little Indies in there I'm just go my
heart on this one so put me down adct
Kon for both what did you say King he
said cocon as well
okay yeah I said conun and my heart is a
viewfinder
okay okay
[Music]
I you want me to go so yeah go ahead
okay I'm
saying I'm saying Pizza finder Pizza tow
Pizza Tower cuz I heard a lot of drama
for that game for it not to be anything
and I'm going say c
[__] would be my want shout out to Jason
B Planet Alana was snubbed I agree agree
for sure thank you lyan m exactly I
agree everybody's good uh no I didn't go
yet oh s s what you doing what you doing
sof damn see I need that nice little
banana peel for me right here that's
what see cocoon cocoon can have the
recency
bias the pizza Tower rated slightly
better where we going that how how does
it feel to have that giant red mark on
the back of your
head that's F Crown your lord if he wins
this year if he wins this year I demand
he picks first every time yo he he had
that red mark on the back of his head
every time we came and played wrestl uh
WWE he had de Linko oh God de Linko what
Chris Ben yeah Chris Ben oh God the
cross cross face here
I had to have some unbeatable
dude
goldber the vote is ticking damn it tick
tock sound sound like pizza tow to you
that's what it sounds like sound like
you want to say cocoon you know what it
is I think if I'm not mistaken Pizza to
go with C I think I don't think Pizza
Towers I don't think Pizza tow is on
anything but PC still you know I've got
to the point where I'm okay losing I
just don't want Cog winning all this
he sound like he want to go Pizza tow I
don't know why he fighting
it say with your chest say pizza Tower
with your chest let's get that banana
pill in there right
here this is the mess up I'm I'm g go
yeah I'm a mess up but I'mma mess up
with you so I'm g go
cocoon that's I'm go cocon because of
recency bias and multiple platforms but
I think yeah my heart would be Pizza
Tower it's going to be interesting when
we read it off if it was pizza Tower we
going with your hearts damn your logic
uhhuh next let's go add
next all right independent game here we
go the
controversy the
DI for outstanding creative and
Technical achievement in a game made
outside the traditional publisher system
outside cocoon is back Dave the diver a
point of massive contention
sign in the v not an independent game
shout out to M rocket shout out to next
next shout out shout out to you having a
real and you f what you got I'm uh my
what I think what I yeah what I want is
the both SE
Stars adct I'm jumping right in there
this is I think this is the shot for CA
Stars this is the legit chance otherwise
it's going to be tough cuz Dave look
Dave the D is fire I know we don't agree
that it should be here based on the
category
verbiage which could win based on the
fact that they forcing it damn I got to
think about they all forcing Dave the
diver in here for a
reason yeah just to
[Music]
lose I'mma go up my heart I'm this is my
banana pel see a star is supposed to win
something man hey won already I said
it best RPG bro all right yeah I'm g go
see his Stars for the Indie joint and
keep the Purity hopefully they get
enough backlash and
pressure not the F for I could be wrong
I can mess up this is my banana pill
moment yeah CF stars for me as well CO's
like no banana moment God man this gu
getting on my nerve right now C stars
for both yes okay oh SE a stars for me
as well if you find it is in my heart
but um I think seia stars is that much
of an incredible game and I don't think
a lot of people got a chance to play
game be honest with you and if you have
Game Pass just go try it out man please
shout out to Game Pass you know I I
don't know if Sony got it over there but
I know we got it over here man they do
have it over there they do they have it
in I would know cuz I only go for
exclusive that's what talk about fair
enough go you ridiculous I don't I don't
go to McDonald's and just go uh go get a
regular burger man I go for the the Big
Mac Man
continue
o this is crazy
best community spot recogniz going be
the easiest the easiest point for Cog
not to pick Destiny 2 recognizing a game
for
outstanding Community Support
transparency and responsiveness
inclusive of social media activity and
game updates patches you know I got to
go with Destiny 2
not not happening thisy D not your heart
this year no way no how how are you
supposed to be here how dare you show up
to this party and uninvited watch the
destiny wins that would be wild wow well
they all under Sony banner and they all
trying to save Kong I'm pull I'm pulling
the I'm pulling the the card s you gotta
go first why I gotta go
first I gotta go I I want to see what
the panel
has no come on you got to go D you
you've been outvoted three to one going
first wow I didn't even vote he vote he
put his
put his in all right uh I feel like no M
guy is here all the time here all the
time is definit all the time it's
definitely not Destiny I mean balers is
a game that was built with the
community I
think damn it man here we go a hard one
this is a hard one who going to get it
watch me watch me this social media
activity and game
upes
patches I mean I never felt like I never
felt it kind of feels like this category
is made some the for the moments right
for the moments like when something
really goes left and they fix it me I'm
doing I'm doing cyber pump I'm doing
cyber pumpk guy I I feel like this
sucker sucker this is the come this is
the comeback moment you know the I I
feel that yes it's there yep that's what
I'm the same boat damn it what's your
heart what's your heart my heart my
heart would be cyber Punk man I want
them to get that you know they they they
fixed that game and I again I don't
never want to blame the devs for what
happened so um this is their chance to
get some shine back so I'll say that I'm
an exact boat I think this this C is
made for cyber Punk to have the the the
magical moment CD Project R come out on
stage this to M A kopa you know yeah
yeah this is how they getting this one I
think this one one of the few I feel
balers gate will lose even though you
can make a strong AR B
gate okay well okay yeah I'm I'm I'm
agreeing with them by the way oh hold on
that Jean though he said what the hell
is CD project red doing on social media
though yeah that part um I see
Destiny as overse I'm still thinking by
the way a lot okay keep thinking um see
overseeing a lot of Sony projects so
they bigger than who you think they are
and they you know they got more money to
burn B oh you go Destiny I'm gonna say
bunie coming out on stage this is the
year that Destiny gets it um for the
simple fact they under the Sony
umbrella um and this my this is where
Sony tax is real be this is Sony tax
then cuz Sony ain't win a game of the
year we give Sony as much stuff as
possible because they want to put cuz
see Destiny at his alltime low right now
they're trying to get you guys back Sony
is bleeding cash they trying to save
this is where this whereing go this is
the perfect one I need I cannot wait
till when we turn up and you dudes that
love didn't vote for Destiny and this
dude that walked away from Destiny voted
for Destiny because you going back next
week to play Destiny I'm going to tell
you that's right that's what I'm tring
don't mean it's the best community
support yeah for real
definitely I'm going to say we got you
we we locked you in you over there yeah
I'm in with that but cyber Punk is is my
uh vote for my heart all right add um I
think I'mma Be the outlier on here and
I'mma I'mma go I'mma shoot for the stars
and try to win a quick one I'm going to
say boers Gate 3 is winning this and I
want cyberpunk win this this is a good
play by adct I like what you're doing I
like what you're doing cuz part of me
thinks that there is no better Community
Support than the community building your
game with you you got a
argument I
might you get Game of the Year you don't
get nothing else best ongoing game
awarded to a game for outstanding
development of ongoing content that
evolves you already know who already won
this I'm going first fortnite yes this
is where we get y' can say gen and
impact all you want fornite he going to
go with his heart this where we
get yo this is this is where I fall all
over the floor I'm going with fortnite I
fortnite and my heart
fortnite I know he vot with fortnite
oh yeah it's fortnite I mean you this is
this is the category this a category
that comes back around that you know you
get you get the same nominee and then
you know everybody has their turn I
think it's fortnite's turn again and
with them I guess they there's a reset
in a couple of days right yeah it's
fortnite I'm watching the rocket hit the
floor right now yeah going G is that is
that your want
to uh my
want my I don't understand cyberp Punk
being here I know right I want to know
that I really care about the other ones
like that yeah for fortnite I you
know addict Apex Legend
H I'm going to
laugh you know what he said I'm going
you know what what's up you turn my
mindset I'm going fortnite too I feel
you to video tape I'm just curious um
statisticians uh have they won who won
ongoing last year was um fortnite won
last year it kind of I don't remember
fortnite winning fin fantasy I think it
was I don't remember fortnite we winning
this award for some reason but they be
hating on fortnite well see here's the
thing the reason that I want I I I went
with fortnite is cuz I do think them
going back to the OG map really got
their Community going it like my want is
Final Fantasy 14 because I love when
Final Fantasy wins uh but I don't think
it's going to beat fortnite because I
I've heard a lot about Final Fantasy but
people wouldn't shut up about fortnite
when when when that they I I just think
it's it's it's kind of fair just to look
at which game had the most content and
the most crazy stuff going on in it
every year so the question is car do you
do you go with safy do do do do do you
stay not walk in front or do you walk in
front and fall down
because probably feels they try to
shoehorn a certain guy in here for a
reason
do that don't need to be his is sh up
the only the only question is do you
walk with salver
again I know I know look we all know
fortnite's supposed to win this the
problem the issue is are they the Cyber
Punk and I just I don't know man I just
I just see CD project man keep coming up
on stage it just doesn't feel like it's
an ongoing game like this is this this
is L this literally does not belong
agree I agree I ain't locking yet I
ain't locking yet who um didn't you're
lock nope nope nope I'm not locked in
did EP is it epic gam sponsoring this
Awards let me see this year isep yes yes
they are oh never mind I'll take it back
fortnite's winning this fortnite already
fornite's winning this never mind they
got you got a sponsoring Buck they got a
hand in the pot they got the hand in the
pot Tim Tim Sweeney in the back
hugging tears of joy o games for impact
for a thought-provoking game with a pro
social meaning on hold on let me just
let me just shout something out real
quick shout out to my man Luke Bernard
who was supposed to be here who had a
light in the darkness a game literally
that was free about the Holocaust should
have been here that's all I'm saying I'm
done my ramp I we've all went first this
time car goes first that's true I've
been fronting I've been I hope you
noticed oh this one is the worst one for
me to work too oh no I'm mess for impact
yeah space CU then I can decide if I
want to try to fight Cog CH I played we
played at packs but I didn't feel was
okay goodbye Vol a lot of these I don't
even know about to Cher that's why
you're going
for I hear good things about
Vena I he I'm GNA go Vena I'm going to
go V I'm going mess this this is
completely a mess up for me cuz most of
these games I have not played but VBA
I've heard good things about so that's
where I'm
at is that both both V
both okay let me see
um who do I know here my heart is light
in the darkness but it ain't here
um CH go play that goodbye
volcano
B I'm going to look at uh cover
art who got the hot cover is he blust I
know this man did not
say I ain't play none of this I don't
even
know who did they impact cuz they impact
me but um impact Game Pass that's why
you you ain't know about it that's the
impact yo and this is for y'all that get
this y'all G to get this impact I don't
know none of y'all and y'all need to
make sure y'all make your way over the
Microsoft ecos system so I'm gonna go
with vot Vach because I know Vis real
games and that's that's about it and my
heart my heart is a games with a real
game with impact
but but thank you guys I
appreciate for both yeah
s what are you doing s you want me to go
first no no no no he got let's see what
he
do a space for the Unbound damn it what
he know know this joint too probably
damn it space for the unb sop's Googling
the games right now yeah I I feel this
way he catch up cuz I don't know I don't
know none of these games I don't know
none of these games either okay I'm just
going my numbers here you doing metrics
hey Chad put what you think's gonna win
in the chat I would have liked to have
seen they said vble was on Game Pass
they calling us out yeah vble was on
game you call me out all you want I got
I got but so much time don't you mess
with me man I calling you out king
should but no I didn't it should have
stayed longer 500 likes hit the likes
y'all hit the likes we having fun come
on um yeah I think it's a space for the
Unbound but um I would have liked to
seen
Chia
Chia um it was like it's supposed to be
kind of a br can't believe he just
did all right everybody's
in is die
oh my God you said tiia yeah yeah okay I
am copying uh
s both all right everybody's votes in
let's move on we get into the heavy
hited soon eventually oh
God I'm I just
gotta
okay innov o this a hard one innovation
in accessibility recognizing software
Hardware that is pushing the medium
forward by adding features Tech and
content to help games be played and
enjoyed by a wider audience Diablo
4 Forza
Motorsport highi Rush Marvel Spiderman 2
Mortal
Combat why why you mad that the
Spider-Man's in here okay so Innovation
and access accessibility right what the
hell a did it do the game just came out
again this is just a reskin so it should
be here any time right no man get him
out of here we say Kong on this one can
you web for free can't you web swing for
free in there get him out of here that
that was done
already combat one right Street Fighter
6 now remember accessibility y'all
Innovation I got to go with Street
Fighter what they do they do that stupid
uh uh easy controlas easy they do that
yo I was fighting for my life in this
house because these dudes put it on easy
I'm like how going Street Fighter who I
want who I really want want to win yeah
none of those games is accessible like
Diablo is not access for is not high
five Rush isn't Spider-Man damn heart
though my heart my heart got to be
Mortal Kombat you know they did some
stuff for accessibility
so Street Fighter though that easy mode
that's a killer yeah it's crazy yeah
that's crazy dude beat you
jumping in who jumping in there I'm a
say Forza I'm I'm I'm a stand I'm a
stand out for this one uh what I would
like to win would be high five
Rush
interesting Sofie quiet I well not four
not four um what you got high five yeah
Street fter six oh go with his yes yes
see five to six at my heart would
be high five Rush yeah this is very
difficult cuz three games here actually
have extreme advancements and
accessibility two games you could play
Blind I'm going with
addict yeah I think Forza has so many
accessibility
modes high five Rush does too though I'm
not going to say it don't Is Your Love
highi Rush my heart is high five I think
Forza just did enough with the wheel all
that here's the thing when it comes to
this particular one uh I am locking
everyone's down so you can't switch yeah
I don't think I don't think they're
going with straight fighter because I I
think that just makes it more casual
it's not that setting is not about
accessibility it's about making doing
Combos and stuff easier I feel wasn't
changing what I said okay well that's
fine when um it it goes to like making
something accessible it's like color
blind issues you know you know things
like that that's why I don't I I feel
like you know Forza cuz Forza did a lot
yeah we got we got soft locked in good
let's move on let's move you know what I
forgot about the let's move on let's go
let's move on Go performance award
to individual for voice acting voice
over acting motion and or performance
capture choices are Ben star Final
Fantasy 16 Cameron M monin Star Wars
Jedi Survivor uhoh strer Bell e just
Elba cyber Punk Melanie leird Alan wink
to why you got the curses over the
people like you gonna pick those Neil
NewBo balers Gate 3 or King's favorite
Yuri Lal Marvel Spider-Man 2 who was he
he was Peter
Parker he said what was he Yuri lenthal
is M
Morales
well I wouldn't
be I would I I wouldn't be surprised um
but I'm just saying I'm just saying
like when are voice actors not starting
to look like these characters these
characters are looking way different
doesn't Spider-Man doesn't Pete Parker
look like Jim Ryan I'm um like Star Wars
come on that's literally him I'm I'm you
know that's really him that's
him know my I know my no no I'm going
with you going with
yeah my is Str Idis let's go okay Whois
Idis Elba Elis Alba Ela I know what my
vote is my vote is Ben star Final
Fantasy 16 he been out in these streets
streets
crazy and my heart would be Melanie
leird Al we too okay yeah I got Ben I
got Ben that that he sold a whole demo
at the end yeah yeah he did what's your
bastards my heart my heart is Absol ster
elbow got I love him that's my man so
both Ben
star no your heart my Ben star is my
pick and my heart is IA help okay he'll
just step up there let them know you
don't say you uh mine what is yours King
your heart oh my heart uh would be the
the Star Wars guy Ben star y yall F Star
Wars say Ben star I say Ben star I said
Star Wars you know the dude that played
The Joker Cameron
mon all right so I am voting for Cameron
oh and I uh my heart would also be
Cameron oh I think I think in terms of I
think he played a fantastic you know so
he yeah got
got him welcome to the
dog do the H go seep in let's
go it's fine you're locked in let's move
on let's move
on now done now you're
[Laughter]
done best audio design recognizing the
best in-game audio and sound design Alan
waight
to dead I'm going high five
Rush Marvel Spider-Man 2 and Resident
Evil 4 this is kind of Stack I'll go
first it's kind of
stacked what you got I am my want and
who I think is gonna win is GNA be high
five
rush I think this is one of the few ones
that they have a real big shot of
winning outside Allan W who is crazy
with the yeah but I feel like they're
going to look at highi rush and say this
this game was literally designed around
best audio design like okay okay okay
right anybody else jumping out the
window I'll jump out yeah it's um I
think I mean literally the game is built
around audio design so I think it's high
five but in my heart in my heart that
Dead Space yeah Dead Space five I think
you should do that N I don't think
so I'm G hold my head you I think you
should do it man I think I I'm with you
KS on
Zoom my zoom no king king's is muted at
Zoom for some reason he's got to check
his Zoom he said hold on all right so he
figuring he doing something he talking
to some he's Googling the game he's
Googling something add you already
devoted right I jump in while King's
waiting this is
tough Allan Wake 2 really does have a
legitimate shot deserve it is amazing
but addict is right this category is
literally made in is like the the intent
like the whole essence of high-f five
Rush is is music and audio and onbeat
timing
like yeah like the stages beats were
designed for for it's highi like I'm
sorry yeah the entire game moves to a
rhym rythm is that your heart too yeah
it's both I want I want my man John
Johannes okay again shout out to him
interviewed him in the real this is his
flower this is his moment he got to come
out there it's
mine is high five rush and my heart is
um Dead Space uh the only reason why is
when I'm playing dead space the ambient
noise and the Stu that's going on it's
crazy put that put the headphones on and
turn the lights off you're in trouble
you think you're in the space station
facts I just want to let y'all know
though Allan Wake is that energy too
though oh no no yeah for sure played it
I played it yeah all right cool let's go
best score and music oh damn man
it's hard actually you can make an
argument Dam can I get back I know who
going win this I know who going win this
wo best score and music for outstanding
music I went first last time I'm not
going first all right I'll go first okay
goad Final Fantasy I got Final Fantasy y
yeah y'all trying to say Kong I'm with
Final Fantasy on this one I'm not going
to lie they they musical score is dope
um yes he's in he's locked we got him
y y'all can say whatever yall want to
say we
got um my heart it it would be you know
high five rush but I think I think um
Final Fantasy get now we do realize gate
and the kingom is in this category you
know what's funny we're we're going the
direction we think the industry is going
all almost all of King's reasons for a
pick is because of Xbox tag yeah
everything Xbox tax related all right
when y'all look up and yall say Sony did
it again
yeah I know who pulled out and Who had
who back when something happened St what
you doing Final Fantasy what you doing
I'm curious what you Big
B yeah thing about Alan Wake is like
Alan Wake after every chapter you have a
song and that song is built for that
chapter like it is literally a song
built for that chapter um but I I'm I'm
a king I think I I think the masss are
going Final Fantasy 16 and oh you know
what I forgot didn't dud have cancer or
something didn't he have like a medical
issue that everybody's going like
rallying for him yes yes yes yes
dur so what's your what's your want uh
your your heart my heart would be Allan
Wake too my heart is
Starfield but it's not here
so in memory of my man I'm going with
the high five Rush Clean Sweep I'm going
for the sweep I he going to come back
back up they going they going to have
mad trophies they going to be like see
King Ain't No Xbox
tax he going to have like four gold
chains on his neck when he come up John
Joan is was swaying like what's good we
we got another one he gonna point the
fileld see I told you and they gonna
also have Game of the Year inside game
pass with Boulders
game whatever y'all saying is not going
to stop crazy thing is the crazy thing
is if you have the mind that Bowers is
going to mostly sweep everything that is
in then then yeah we in trouble yeah we
all in trouble because Bal bald's music
is good too I I'm I'm stepping away from
all of you on this one I'm saying
Zelda I actually feel like there there's
not there's a possibility Zelda doesn't
walk away of any reward but I think this
is one of the few they will walk
away not that
guy not that guy but I'mma tell you this
not he going to win he going to win
other stuff but right now h no Final
Fantasy this is a tough category this is
a tough category I don't even cap for
Final Fantasy like that but everybody's
got their votes in yes sir oh best art
Direction I'm going
last Allan Wake 2 outstanding creative
and Technical achievement in artistic
design and animation high five rush back
in the mix so
shad eyes of PE nice little debut in
here Super Mario
wonder and the old cheese coming through
with Zelda this is tough this is tough I
I think I speak for everyone C you're
going first is three to one oh art
Direction all right let's break this
down
logically when he goes first he's got to
break it down this down logically look I
love lies of P art Direction
I just don't think you got you can't you
ain't got enough arms to box the Gods in
here I think the gods are just even
though you should should have an
opportunity to win this there's just
certain heavy weights you're not this is
not your weight class in here High far I
love you but I think this is where your
your gold chains slow down now you've
had you've had fun in what you
do Alan
Wake man I want you to win something
you've got to win something but is this
where you win with these monsters in
here these absolute
bits oo now here's the interesting
thing anytime I see wonder I say you in
here you're going to win every time I
see tears to the kingdom I say you go
they're in it together which means
they're going to cancel each other out
you think they're going to cancel each
other I mean this is technically
there's enough people to vote for both
of them to to help someone else out yeah
yeah oh man you want me to go first do
you want hold on hold on hold on hold on
hold on um damn this is hard though all
right I'm gonna
say this is where the Nintendo tax
really starts to kick in the Nintendo
rebate start to kick
in which one
right
okay I don't see Mario Wonder beating
him in terms of a game of the year thing
but I'm going to start the Zelda train
now I'm GNA start my Zelda train I think
Zelda for some reason is going to start
now getting their chains up I'm I'm
gonna go with Zelda on this one I it's
not my choice my heart is
actually my heart is actually Allan Wake
too I think Allan W 2 should win this
should get a shot but I think the
Nintendo train is is about to get get
cooking so yeah I'm going L this is a
hard one I'm going mess up I can mess up
I'm actually part of me wants to lean
towards Liza P I feel like there's not a
lot of games like that but I'm gonna I'm
going to land on Super Mario because
some of the the the some of the design
they did on this game beautiful is just
is absolutely like Bonkers so I can just
them winning Co is hilarious no it's
beautiful no no no he actually I'm
actually not being
sarcastic he's I should have I could
have really flipped my vote with the
Nintendo games and go with because that
this is the shot for Mario to beat Zelda
here based on the colorful the m i he's
got a good point I just want to see how
they play it I don't know how they
voting this year it's a tough
one um okay so I got next yeah yeah yeah
I was going to go Liza p and I was only
going to go Liza P because I don't see
Liza P winning anything this year other
than this because the direction is
almost Pi Liza yeah it's a it's a
beautiful looking game it plays well the
art direction is incredible but at the
end of the day I don't know how the hell
you give me
Mario being a new art like it's it's the
same but it's really different and you
can point out every little thing that's
different and when he gets those musom
the thing is you read it it says
outstanding creative and Technical
achievements in art artistics design and
animation well that's zeld is definitely
not there um okay so we dis that that
will have to be no I'm gonna disrespect
high five rush but y don't got enough
today
stop um Allan Wake then I'm g go out you
you you have persuaded me with the
outstanding Direction because when you
can have a naked 40s something year old
man
walking boy and you can be like my want
is marri Mario okay yeah so I think C Is
Right They're Gonna Cancel each other
out yeah I'm you might be want me to
redo my
phone now you locked in I'm I locked in
can I can I switch you're locked you're
locked you're locked son doors closed
door's closed gr open it gr closer there
it
is yeah it's Alan
Wake when you look at Allen wake is just
the game that's built like everything
about that game is is we like to use the
word bespoke like it's like that they
like it's built for that moment for that
scenario whether it's a jump scare or
whatever the case may be the mood stuff
the music um them faces look crazy that
uh is
disrespectful he said y'all gotta think
like the absolute clowns who are voting
on this yo that's so disrespectful this
is true it's got true what's what's your
want your heart it's both it's both is
Allen
wake Super Mario is beautiful but it is
just improving upon love to see to see
Hogwarts in here but you know yeah yeah
but you know anyway moving on best
Narrative of outstanding storytelling
and narrative development in a game
Allan Wake two oh balers gate three oh
cyberpunk addict's favorite Final
Fantasy 16 and King's favorite Marvel
Spider-Man 2 SK cyber Punk cyber Punk
fan of
Liberty who's getting the narrative
award here this is tough um I'm going to
go with save
Kong FY n Spiderman save Kong
that's yeah yeah yo all right I don't
know y'all gonna sit there and a lot a
lot of you dudes out there is like y not
King is definitely boldest game without
a d i Ain play yet so I'mma tell you
Spider-Man
uh because everybody's been praising The
Narrative just the way it's going it's
ridiculous you say so yeah this they get
one Spider-Man this didn't get one okay
yeah Spider-Man got something this year
and my heart um narrative wise was the
wi with uh Final Fantasy I thought Final
Fantasy had a very good narrative yeah
did just not for Final Fantasy yeah it
did have a good narrative I I have to
say they got a shot so so your your
heart was Final Fantasy yeah my heart's
Final Fantasy Spider-Man is the win I a
no solve on
this what's the thought process
here what's I think the bers gate is so
like yes it has an overarching narrative
but there's so much stuff that can
change in between that it really is like
D and D like it really is like D and D
it is what the player makes of
it
I give it to Alan
Wake Allan Wake okay okay what was your
heart
heart I'll say Alan WG again
o okay I'll go I'm stepping out and
saying Boulders
gate three this is what weep more ice
more gold chains more gold chains I
would want Boulders gate as well okay to
win uh I I think voters Gate 3 might not
have like a definitive point A to point
B uh but I think this is more than just
you know tearing a telling a story
telling a narrative too and the fact
that you can change the narrative
drastically and bers gate will will give
it the edge I mean Boulders gate
definitely got that that byway energy
that that strong narrative and
choice but I think this is the only shot
Allan Wick has to really set itself from
any other War
and I think they I think Sam Lake look
Sam Lake cool with Jeff man he gotta get
he got to get his flowers man and I may
have messed up while not including them
in the one king pick which I probably
should
have so I'm I'm goingon to go Allen Wick
I think Allen Wick's gonna this is what
they do and yeah both this is what they
do even though Boulders gate is strong
out here I think this and Final Fantasy
got is a is a shot but it just I just
think alen's got so much behind it right
now that's one thing I will give Final
Fantasy it was good but as far as the
rest on this list I think it doesn't
touch from what I've been told about
Allen wake 2 and bers gate three and
even even cyber Punk for that matter I
think that's a a
real good narrative there's only two
more okay this is sa does not go first
here because sa's going first for games
of year because he won last
year wow best game Direction What If for
outstanding Creative Vision and
innovation in game Direction and
design Allan Wake 2 balers Gate 3 Marvel
Spiderman 2 Super Mario wonder and Sela
tear at the Kingdom game Direction y'all
this is it the Heavy Hitters are coming
outside what we doing who goes
first
who these are Point categories who's
going first no s you got to go first for
game of the year so you don't
fine game Direction all right game
Direction um best game Direction awarded
to the outstanding Creative Vision and
innovation of a game Direction and
design um Allan W I picked Allan Wake a
minute ago haven't said anything for
bal's gate because I believe B's gate is
winning game of the year um I believe
people's going to be upset because they
didn't win a lot of stuff Spider-Man
sorry brother um Mario didn't get
anything and you're not winning game of
the year Zelda already gave you
something so already gave you something
I'm going I'm already I'm going with
super mar out candy that's right just
just participation
so Mario and and my heart um for best
game direction would be Zelda and what
what sucks is about it is I lost so much
interest in it in under 10
hours so we saying that Zelda only Come
Away with like one award this show I
don't think they're G to get any awards
I think they get one wow okay mhm all
right I'm jumping in
um this is a tough
category W's got great Direction in a
way in itself in a way
too Marvel was great but more the same
you know in a way mhm um Alan wi's got
good G
direction to comes down to balers gate
and Zelda Zelda was very
Innovative
um but I think this is definitively what
what balers gate three does I just think
they they brought the DND D in the game
yeah
this I got it's going to be tough I
could see Zelda winning this but I'm
going to give balers gate this one
that's where I'm going go with it I
think they get another another gold
chain so that's where I'm
going
I okay you said um you said Boulders
gate
mm three and what do you want to
uh for My
Heart techically Barry would should get
a little love should get a little love
for the little little creativeness in 2D
space I'm going with alen wake 2 winning
this and I want bers Gate 3 to win it
because I feel like the industry really
really liked Island wake to and I feel
like it's not going to win game of the
year most likely so I think they're
going to give it best game Direction
because I can see it being on this list
everybody is saying Zelda is showing up
for no reason they should stay home they
are not winning we gave Z we gave Zelda
something else I don't remember y'all
giving zeld to anything I I we can look
after this we'll go through all them no
I think the puzzle the puzzle something
puzzle something i' gave I gave it more
than just about out here tears of the
Kingdom going to walk home with a stink
face okay hold up and no change let's
see who pick zeld okay so we do got to
go back for these first two cuz I didn't
get them all no Zelda no Zelda no Zelda
no Zelda mm no Zelda no Zelda Z here is
the Zelda okay best action adventure
okay so we did give okay okay we did
give him action adventure no Zelda no
Zelda no Zelda no Zelda no Zelda no
Zelda no okay I said for best scored
music uh Cog you said for best art
Direct
and yeah that's where we now let's
go it's it's off now it's off reing
Champion reigning Champion decisions
um see thing about go Boulders gate
three is that everybody's acting like
it's brand
new bald this game been around a long
time yeah the concept has been there
forever this is the one of the this is
one of the very few this is one of the
very few that I feel like Spider-Man
shouldn't be here in Starfield should be
here like to me best game direction is
like doing something that's never been
done before to a point or doing
something that very few people have done
and I feel like the comic book scene's
been done a lot so it shouldn't be here
I feel like Starfield should be there of
going if he's not going Bal dis gate
three I mean the most directed game this
year feels like outweight too it is is a
game that is is that every moment every
moment is created to evoke something so
um I think that's Sam Lake all the way
um the throning Zelda lock him in lock
him in lock him in
now tie him down now the moment I put
that twoo it's a w it is Allan Wake and
Allan Wake could be my heart too but I
I'm so in love what Mario did I'm going
give the heart to Mario here okay same
um but again it is them just continuing
to improve the form they created
so that's it we need like a you know
what we should do we should have a uh a
a what's what a a shirt made for a limit
of a time this ISS lock him in lock him
in all right the heavyweight fight is
here and Sol's going first the
two-pointer the one that breaks Hearts
every year you get an extra point you
get this right Game of the Year
recognizing the game that delivers the
absolute best experience across all
creative and Technical Fields Allan Wake
two balis gate three King Spider-Man 2
no one's
resident Ain nothing about that shout
out to Starfield though Super mar from
this and Legend of Zelda tears of the
king this is the heavyweight match up
who is coming on that stage or you know
they going to play the orchestra for all
the songs all the Gams the music
everybody going to get
emotional tax or not
king um I'm not emotional at all game of
the year game of the year is bers gate
three beating now beating now Zelda I
put a it's it's gonna beat the hell out
of Zelda it's gonna beat the hell out of
Mario is going to definitely be
the listen bers gate three Phil's going
to come out and he's going to accept the
um what I wish though I really you know
what's crazy if that actually happened
that would be hilarious yeah and and
that's when I'm a prophit for real and
it's
over that's that's when it's over real
for real the last time I said something
that happened um is G three you've been
locked yeah yeah I care I'm locked um
because it's going in Game Pass uh
Spider-Man would have been I really wish
it would have been different man I know
no no I really do I gotta go play the
old one now
addict
um two points can make a break a cronia
lord two
points oo he's writing it B this gate
three the uprising the young champ got
it as
okay okay
okay battle lies of draw so s goes last
that's how this go cuz he last go damn
it no Sol went first oh he went first no
I didn't go cuz King jumped in oh Sol go
damn it man yeah why we a let s
go we already knew what s was gonna
do let's go s what we doing see y it's
funny because we talk about Mario and
and Zelda but the two most nominated
games Allan Wake and balers gate
three and actually Alex has a conspiracy
theory Allan Wake 2 is as per as per my
list I'm getting a lot of Red Dead Vibes
where it's like I don't like the fact
that c gotta go last in this like I'm
getting Red Dead Vibes where it feels
like Allan wig is gonna win a lot of
these it's kind of like a latee darling
um and then not win game of the year
which makes sense to me yeah that's
right B is gate so it is to me and I'm
going to go I'm going to go with the
People's Choice and and probably go I'm
going balers gate three but my
heart even above Zelda which I haven't
played but again it's Zelda um but my
heart is my heart is alen Wake Alan Wake
but balers gate wins this but I think
overall overall I think Allan Wake wins
more award I think you need to do that n
no that's that's all right I'm good need
to set the tone
y already said it for me I'm the third
to go this is tough for me see what's
funny King is we
somehow the person that wants to win the
most is going last and game and this is
why I always mess
up n it's you already know what it is I
mean but do we yeah we do do we Okay
this
is I I hope I hope I hope he don't you
know look at the the two uh fake dudes
that's there I mean there and then you
got one dude that definitely should not
be there one dude that anytime he show
up it's a championship yeah there's a
dude out here that every time he is
present it goes his way but that but but
that dude always fighting corny people
he ain't fighting corny people this time
he fight he fighting other champion this
dude is beloved by the people in the
panel he's never lost so y saying this
the six of next month and not only y'all
say this dude G lose yo tell me how
about to drop the ball at the not only
y'all said this dude g l y'all said he
not even going to come away with much
Hardware at all he going to get sent
home packing not like
this if if you look if you look at the
amount of times he was nominated overall
this hey one thing one thing I will say
is you could win because of this
choice I got to do something crazy it it
is a two-pointer it is he said I gotta
do something I gotta jump out the window
no you don't like sometimes you gotta
take the you got to take the risk to be
great like no you
don't like you are fine like all all
your stuff made sense till right now but
this what's the definition of
sity the jaws of Victory somebody
slipped my man of
Mickey cuz right now he was all cool and
calm and then he said he got his just
got crazy I've never seen this dude lose
he G lose this one dude up here L this
time this time he G get link has never
lost mind you tied for balers gate as a
top rated game of the year you know
what's funny who got the higher meta
critic let's do same what's B Better
Credit 95 95 or 96 what's tears of the
Kingdom
um6 so they both 96
yeah I'll tell you who gonna get knocked
out this
year and and I'mma let you know who
going in game man I really want to do to
the kingdom man king is 98% right all
the time I really want to do tears of
the Kingdom
but lorder turn base got to go L turn
base I got to do it for the culture I
got to do it for the culture this is
hard I want to go tears I want to be
real I want to do tears of the kingdom
and this if tears of the Kingdom win
this I'm going be so mad at
myself because it would follow protocol
but just for
termbase and my heart more turnbas games
for the culture for them to educate
themselves on damn it on genres that
they don't know nothing
about I got to go for ball this gate
just for pris and I can lose this but
hey I go down I'm swinging with s on
this one all right and I get if King get
his vote
and and they say Game Pass I'm feel real
good about it I'm feel real good go go
go down with what what did I pick I
picked no I'm saying if I you pick I
saying I want to lose I lose and not not
to your benefit okay so we we lose
together that's what I want to do I I I
can't I want to jump out the window the
coaches I'm with you Forte I know and I
this could be my critical mistake to be
great there's a point of me that says
dare to be great but man this
Myer pressure exists for a reason Forte
I'm with you bro he's yo Forte's egging
Bey all to do it too for I know them TS
in the Kingdom in that game stop moving
he's already locked in it's over it's
over over it's over he already made
choice for I want to switch back you
can't persuade anything sorry Forte he's
in Tu December 7th dog loses
again dog might win this year
I I take I had to take a couple more
risks I had to take a coup I win that
Destiny joint I'm gonna rub it all over
your for for for a long time man oh man
you saw that
Forte okay real quick real quick uh bet
um I just needed these first three I I'm
I'm sure if I
got okay uh most anticipated I didn't
get that one at all so I think we all
said Final Fantasy right Final Fantasy
me all right what was uh Cog what was
your want Final Fantasy my want was
Tekken come on okay his want was Tekken
um my want was Star Wars said 20 million
bro M and mine was Hades my one nice
yeah Hades is I be mad as hell te wi
that
fantasy M as that [__] you did two you
pick Final Fantasy hell yeah I'm trying
to
win this is twice this is twice my heart
M I'm trying to I'm trying to do
something different okay King you
went Final Fantasy yes sir rebirth
recency bias and
your what what was your your want Tekken
no Star Wars
outs everybody got
every everybody everybody like nobody
want that King I like Star
Wars I respect it like I like
turtles
Final Fantasy
reever yo I hate when people do that in
Motor Vehicles yes can they type in in
your name uh David
David all right so uh Cognito you best
uh adaptation both was last of us mine
was Mario s was yours Castlevania and
Last of Us Last of Us was my pick uh
Castlevania was my heart okay the second
one's the heart uh King Last of Us your
pick Mario your heart you said
what oh um um no um yeah yeah Last of Us
in Mario yeah yeah yeah okay Esports
this sounds right this looks right
everything look right correct best
multiplayer these are right yeah okay
just Bing sure you can change my
game no Forte pushing me to the edge man
push me for Forte could you please leave
him alone no P pressure you got those
they got the data points that I need
game where was you when he needed you
for Destiny and I'm going to win that
category fie is not coming out of a St
I'mma show you I'mma show you the dollar
the power power boy's crazy out street
man going respect Sony's name oh good
adct you ripped wrapped up the sharing
yeah yeah we're good all right no doubt
we are good super chats and then we
going I'm yeah I'm going read the super
chats and I got to go I know I know I
know you gotta go all right let me get
these super chats you got Miguel Ivars
with the fivey old Super Chat key next
year looking at that abgs plus bgs plus
ABK showcase channeling that Nate Diaz
energy you're taking everything and I
work for mother effer
wow # Xbox is E3
we got gab Forte member for 47 months
with Bron hello Lords what an amazing
weekend for the state of Michigan I'll
get into that in a later Super Chat
tears for Game of the Year and as always
hey King Boo Boo hey
Forte and y'all guys out there better
not even
try hey he's available hey hey I'm
taking
all right then we got then we got not
champagne champagne champagne
supernova supernova $5 Super Chat
there's three things certain in this
life death Xbox taxes and S Supple
lips that man said Supple wait yo yo yo
y champagne come on man actually
actually there was one mess up uh I
didn't put your your hearts for Esports
uh I think all scared of mine is Pub
pubg I thinkb yeah pubg so you just both
of yours is League of Legends and his is
pubg yeah
okay then we got truckle chuckle five
pound Super Chat balers gate Wins Game
of the Year then Phil jumps on stage and
pulls a Kanye saying I love you balers
but Starfield is way
better that's dope but he gonna say
something totally
different
there we got gab Forte again $10 Super
Chat once again the greatest University
in the land my Michigan Wolverines
vanquished our rivals in the Ohio State
University that three Pete smells great
Buckeye fans I still love y'all see
y'all in 369
days they be taking a sports serious
seriously yeah WEAU I used to be like
that until I start picking a I know you
got to go I just want to quickly your
thoughts yay or nay on culture or should
Xbox save it 100% that is theirs it
should have never gone anywhere else
fact bring it inhouse figure out who's
going to make this game now figure out
what you want the game to be because my
thinking is I mean obviously we
Sean yeah give it to obsidian absolutely
they made two right now decide what you
want it to be do you want it to be a
remake in the vein of like a ff7 and
turn the turnbas into hybrid action
turnbas or make it fullterm based but it
has to be beautiful it has to be
cinematic it has to really be a remake
that stands to- to toe I think with an
ff7 remake or things of that nature has
to dark s let's
go dark s got to do emperor Emperor
things executive 66 they call your do
Sol right there and then because I know
you need um also finish your th and then
I had to I would have just I I mean for
me yes save it that is yours that is
associated with you it should have never
going any place else it is time to bring
that back but you got to do it right and
you decide whether if it's turnbas or
hybrid but I think either way it has to
be a beautiful game it has to be
cinematic it really has to bring that
game back uh as a pure triaa knock your
socks off game got you final question um
this is your topic so I want to let you
get your ball um what were where were
you going with the embrace the layoffs
cuz I'm just going to let you get your
balls off and we going probably skip
that time yeah go go right ahead um you
have to Microsoft yes ink is dry oh ink
is dry they held the bag like King said
they it held the line okay time to
pounce there are some IP there this is
personally for me y need y'all need to
say which one uh you need to go grab up
that Legacy of Kane F this actually you
know what's funny there's so many IPS
they own that they they it could be a
flash sell man
and even if they don't make the games
they can always license them out for
movies and TV shows that's the new big
thing but I mean pick and choose through
what that you know what IPS you you want
from there see if the teams that are
actually working on them have the
expertise to bring out you know whatever
type of game that is I understand you
still need the middle ground game you
still need the doublea game loving going
on on this screen I'm sorry I thought it
was Valentine stay in the realm for
someone but we go oh D that this is
X-rated adct I just joking it's getting
hot over there continue sorry but yeah
my thought sad obviously they they they
they really overstepped they really
really Lin stepped with this and they
they took on all these IP they took on
all of these Dev Studios and did didn't
think about you know what it would take
to bring these things to Market as
viable products that people want to buy
um we saw it with Gollum we've seen it
with other they had them stimulus checks
yeah they they were rocking they were
they were living above their means you
know how when you when you live beyond
your means got you got them stemies boy
you was out here you thought you was Bim
boy oh I mean we saw it they shut down
volition and I'm going to be honest like
I I did not like that Saints Ro reboot y
but
volition give rition the chance to go
back don't make them scared of their old
games and try to make another game in
that vein it's been long enough that I
think people will accept it but now
that's dead right rels to the Wi
so um yeah man grab up whatever IP you
think can be relevant moving forward I
can see if k please um and and and let's
see what's there but obviously though I
want these IP to come back in a real
way some of these really do deserve to
be fullon AAA game so I mean if smaller
Dev Studios make their way to some of
these IP cool but I really do some of
think some of this stuff can be
reimagined into big budget sort of brand
new things we'll see all right no doubt
all right brother enjoy go it's gonna be
a crazy couple of weeks I love yall I'll
hopefully make it next week and the week
after no promises but I love love you
love you too brother love you I will C I
will certainly come on to gloat if I win
you don't need to show up for the crow
your lord results I promise I promise
that all you will be doing is showing up
and passing me your
Crowns All brother enjoy peace no doubt
we're going to go back to the first uh
topic for us which was the actually yes
this next year I want I want a crown uh
a crown your L trophy made yeah we got
to do something for him you win again oh
and when you if you win the next year
the person that has it has to M yeah we
got to take it from like how we used
should do with I'm put it right here
yeah yeah you can remind people who The
champ is all right Colour Captain sa
game Xbox come on that's what we doing
cotour REM make what we
doing they come in there save okay so
this is where I have a bit of conundrum
done with this game right all right they
go in there they save the game the game
doesn't come out to snu oh see see
that's what Sony uh dropped ity Sony
Sony knew that it was good and they
walked away from it the IP was poisoned
because it was Microsoft's dead
fruit um and then XBox guys some some
dudes that never even played the damn
game um oh they need to go get it they
need they you can't have another
scalebound can't have another scalebound
this ain't scale bound boy like I don't
know um if it's not going to be done in
the way of Final Fantasy remake like
it's okay Resident Evil uh 2
remake that stuff I want stuff like that
okay if you're going to remake something
I want you to go down to the to to the
ground I want you to go into a great
Direction I want you to see what the
original plan was did they live up to
the original plan if they didn't live up
to the original plan how can you get to
the original plan um can you do it
episodically can you do certain things
because if you going to be in Game Pass
if you're going to purchase it you can
have one of you can have Cotto as a
episodic game that's inside uh Game Pass
well the same way that they doing Final
Fantasy they breaking that joint up oh
you talking about a full remake stat
okay my bad myad full REM that's taken
um you know give you real chunks of the
first game to get to the hole
um because that's episodic technically
you know you got to wait for part two
you know um Final Fantasy but
um I I'm just like you're damned if you
do you're damned if you
don't but me personally as a person that
play CTO and like the game and you know
I'm a fan of Doc rev re yeah um you know
Malik and everybody I'm I'm gonna tell
you Microsoft if you're gonna do it
don't don't half ass it yeah don't don't
do that because you would do more harm
than good in doing that if you're going
to do it give it a full budget have a a
studio uh mapped out and bring the best
technology going forward to it because
if you mess that up you're
mud yeah I feel that adct Xbox Captain
Save A game can they do it should they
jump in I don't I would like here's the
thing's pissed said XBox if it's legal
for them to do it because I don't know
if I would assume that PlayStation's
dropped all support for this game at
this point you know they they privated
the videos like it does seem like they
were trying to like sever the
relationship they had with the company
and the game so if that has happened and
Microsoft is able to jump in here and
save this game I would particularly only
want it to happen if they actually fund
it and find a good Studio I don't I want
them to do it in house or a studio that
we know would do justice like Lor and
Studios
obsidian yeah if they're going to
Outsource this I yeah let them buy
lauran Studios you're right I don't want
them to I don't want them to to just
throw this to anyone if you're not going
to give it like King said the Resident
Evil 4 Final Fantasy 7 uh remake
treatment just let it go Fair don't
don't don't don't just go any further
want to give you an update from Jason
Shri because remember the talk initially
in the beginning of the week when MADD
he's he's going storm he's going to
storm the capital when he heard was
going to be cancelled he's uh was um
that now Jason sh says can't say whether
the CTO remake will actually come out
but yes two people from saber
interactive tell me they're still on it
despite recent rumors that nobody's
working on the game saber took the
project from Aspire last year as bloom
reported and then Jason says the demo
wasn't egregiously bad or anything like
that the bigger issue was misalignment
between all the parties about scope and
how much progress they can make within a
given timeline so he's saying it's still
on don't know if it's going to come out
and he's trying to say that the devil
wasn't bad but I guess their scope was
either too big and they know how long
it's going to take for him to make it so
now uh saber has it instead of aspire to
to to me I don't really like all that
means is someone's working I I'm sure
there's people working on factions right
now probably not
many probably the only people working on
both of these games is the people that's
deciding if it gets canceled or not so
it's just like I need to like see actual
progression like people what scale right
like I because there could be so many
scopes of scale that these companies
could be working on is there literally
just two like it's just to me if Jason
shrier is unsure if the game's going to
be finished or not right the people that
told him they're working on it they're
really like they not even sure because
to me if the people work on it's like no
everything's good we we settled stuff
we're good but they didn't say that to
Jason sh because he even said he's
unsure so to me at this point the only
people that know whether or not this
game's coming out is us in the future
because even the people working on it
don't know yeah so they don't know if
it's actually going to come out yeah
they said it but they're working on it
now jump in um look I'm with the overall
po point with u mdty and S that I do
feel it should have never gotten here
because bro that joint mdy reminded me
he has the OG Xbox joint only on Xbox it
said only on X this joint was also part
of the Xbox OG box art as a game you
could get with the system so I don't
know why Microsoft let that yeah to me
this is like Mass Effect one energy
where you had something and you you know
what I mean like you let this kind of
slip through so you should have been
first I'm kind of mad that play was able
to jump through salute the PlayStation
like see the foresight but I will
say what the hell did Inspire show Sony
that made them go oh no we are walking
away from this
completely go ahead K what what you what
you think they gave him the the the bill
oh they said they said they they gave
him the Whiteboard and they said okay so
what we have over here this is all the
stuff that we're working on and this is
all the stuff that we plan to achieve
and um right now financially what y'all
have uh this the bub we looking for is
is this right here but what we need to
get to he is this right here and they
slid the note on the table and Jim slid
it back and said not for that price not
not with that engine we won't be going
forward with this relation
bro for Sony to snatch an exclusive and
that is this should be a slam I let you
know how broke they are like y'all got
stop playing around like why can't be
the Aspire joint was not hot no it was
it was hot I know it was hot like yo I
you know what everybody Sizzle real lit
everybody Sizzle real lit until you get
the actual game we saw redz real and we
was like yo that's hot that's hot son
like yo we saw for spoken she was
jumping around that's hot son what if
they came in there spit super ugly nah n
they didn't they didn't I know they came
in there they spent super pricey and
these dudes was like you know how you
going to take a girl out you going to go
eat and she start talking about going to
roof
Cris and she you like she acced to yeah
yeah I could come pick you up she's like
N I meet you at the restaurant just send
the Uber for to get me to go to hell no
like where you at with this you bugged
out so like
Factory and that's what's
happening that's we go to Mr
CH like I want to go to Mr CH
Sai was like no okay so the scope the
budget that's where you were it was the
budget I know these dudes man I know how
broke they are I know when they start
sliding checks across the table you know
how when they send here pay this bill
they push it right back listen this
should have been a slam duck it's Star
Wars and it's existing IP it's a belov
this is like a e you already got the
foundation on the Remake right there
like I I'm shocked that this didn't go
down so that is interesting now saber is
on it my only issue what's up go ahead
imagine imagine announcing you dating my
ex that it come out you couldn't afford
oh man don't do like that like y could
go through with anything I got your girl
like yo I got your boo everybody man oh
man they work with together now then you
come to find out now he couldn't even
they a't even together he can't afford
to dat the keep up with the payments oh
man not like this said I want my hair
and nails done
Sony not like this King not like this
you are messy your financial tell me the
truth so this would have went down if
they could have afforded it that's the
only reason why it couldn't be because
the game itself was not quality they
care if Microsoft would have announced
it we know it was coming
out these dudes talk about they got
stuff coming out we don't know what's
up you're ridiculous y'all couldn't
afford
cot you are ridiculous
anyway oh look all I was going to say is
now obviously saber interactive has it
is a new new person that that's going to
be taking over a new new chick according
the king that has it and um the only
thing I know is like for Xbox is can
they realistically do anything was there
anything contractually in place that say
yo remember when they snab up snagged
the exclusivity Sony did does that end
with a Spire now that saber has it could
somebody jump in could could Xbox do the
double dge jump you know jump in type
jerk we're going to see um I will say I
agree completely with adct
though if Xbox is able to get
involved to me there is only one logical
choice there's only one choice who
should grab this and no disrespect sa
interactive I know you guys forgot the
gentleman name I interviewed him he's
awesome Matthew har they made them um
NBA playground games that I did like but
anyway um back on track the only one who
should be doing this if XBox has control
is the Black Rock obsidian come to the
front of the table you did C to to and
obsidian been known and be like yo is a
project available we love to work with
whoever whatever get him a license IP
Star Wars I would love that to happen if
it's contractually able if obsidian is
free
schedule wise they got a team they want
to do it joshu what's up man josu what's
up that's me that's me but I think it's
it's a slam dunk if again Xbox is able
to and again no disrespect to you saber
but you you can't play with this we it
has to be quality you can't be messing
up C I'm not saying they going to but if
it was up to me I would find out hey
what team do you want Xbox to help out
cuz clearly Sony don't want nothing to
do with this no more for whatever reason
like you want to go with I I'm going
need your help on super chats and then
we just or you want me to just combine
um last topic and then Super Chat to
there and then roll out I think we just
do super chats and and let his
little we just walk out we got super
chats now and then oh you King do his R
all right so we going to switch over
PlayStation
lawsuit is off and uh set up King's
topic oh my God where oh hold on did I
find it that's is hold on I think I lost
this thing for a second I had his notes
all up now I can't find the damn thing
give me a second K take us take us to
the
Zone I got give me a second he he he
likes to set it up I got to set him up
cuz he said gotta send me that link from
The Joint give me one second I pull it
up right there cuz he put it in the chat
I must have deleted the thing when I was
doing the what you call it you're so
rude so read Super Chat while I get this
while I get it together okay uh I'm
trying to figure out exactly the last SC
thing he
read um did he read gaming Forte once
again the greatest University in the
land by Michigan Wolverines vanished our
rivals in the Ohio State University that
Three Peaks okay so he read that uh Tim
with the $2 Super Chat I think bers gate
theory for Xbox will drop at the tga's
opinions yeah I think we said that
earlier we all think it's gonna be a
shadow drop found it we and uh we got a
$5 Super Chat from uh Senpai uh iron
Lord's podcast King got Forte s got
joystick adct got that one dude and uh
but who got for who got for Lord beefy
nobody we good two 299 Australian uh
Super Chat from uh risk for the
biscuit go get it Xbox got a $5 Super
Chat from uh from Reggie shout out to
the Lords for another great one I think
a lot of these third party dudes are
required uh Xbox make funded games
multiplat and Xbox is saying
no pretty much saying that these third
party be like if you fund our game it
has to be multiplay and I just don't
think that's how the business Works
father Gucci I can't read anything you
saying about you and the beef so you
ain't in color so I can't read
it sorry Cog has no one continue do we
we all C on yeah yeah all right no doubt
that definitely found it um yeah this is
uh King's topic let's make sure I got
the light on the correct topic yep
PlayStation lawsuit shout out to ruers
Sony facing
7.9 billion Mass lawsuit over
PlayStation store prices Sony must face
this uh lawsuit where over claims the
PlayStation maker abused its dominant
position leading to unfair prices for
consumers the the London tribunal ruled
on Tuesday so siie was sued last year on
behalf of nearly 9 million people in the
UK who had brought digital games or
add-on content through the PlayStation
Store Alex uh Neil is the consumer
Advocate who's bringing this case
against Sony oh it's it she she um says
the company abused its dominant position
by requiring digital games and add-ons
to be bought and sold only via the
Playstation stores which charges a 30%
commission to developers and Publishers
they claim alleged cust customers have
therefore paid higher prices for games
and add-ons than they would have and
they said uh Sony's lawyers had argued
that this this was a flaw case it should
be thrown out but the competition appeal
tribunal said that the uh Neil's case
should continue and that um people who
made King studid who made plac ISS store
purchases after the case was filed in
2022 should be removed from the proposed
claimant class so yeah Neil says this is
the first step in earning consumers
ensuring consumers get back with their
old Sony did not immediately respond to
requests for comment King man oh man
y'all big out in the UK
hey oh
man I love you
wanks shout out to the
bles you
bles have messed with the wrong consumer
we canum and you give us what we need oh
oh my Lord at the same time Sony you
don't gouge us and we found out what you
been up
to so we got a group of our guys
together and we're coming for your
wallets you
see and we got a good chance being that
you don't really win
nowadays yo
7 something billion this is so much fun
yo I told y'all when y'all was going to
go down y'all was going to go down
screaming screaming yo y'all are never
going to recover from this you got the
people that y'all went over yall
remember that y'all strong in the
UK they my
peoples at y'all now now they found out
what y'all was really doing when the
paperwork came out this is why Jim is
gone man
I see right now all right financials are
saying that your guys is close to
bankruptcy this could be the one that
tips y'all over the
edge this could be reports have said
they're going backr reports have come
out from Financial
advis I don't like you in this
accent he have come out and said that
you have been a little bit for
gazy in
it
it govern Governor de was
man you don't know I'm just man they got
watch emojis in the champ the best part
about this right now is like when I wake
up and I said yeah I knew this right you
can't get their steam Keys no place else
like you know like when you get steam
Keys you can get them stuff from any
place other other plac to sell uh
digital codes for Stuff same thing with
Microsoft you could purchase digital
codes from all types of sites that is
correct Sony you cannot do that D yeah
that's true right so that's a
monopoly flag on the
pl flag on the
pl substitution
ref flag on the play they call flag on
the play on gy substitution ref we got
we got hii
harui
haruu hoki to Toki
Siri
Haru
I'm telling you the best part of this is
seeing all y'all act like it ain't
really happening and I told you this is
really happening it's a real lawsuit
happening they really said y' the lawyer
said we should throw this out the judge
said I don't think so let's hear them
out the paperwork says that they can
only get stuff from you is this true he
said yeah this is true you can't buy
none our Goods any place else there why
would I let my goods
go over to the next guy you see I got to
pinch him I got to get mine off the top
well look at
popey they're about to squeeze your
spinach so you implying that their their
control of the PlayStation Store where
they're the only place in town is a
monopolistic practice that they are now
getting flagged for oh this is this is
this is the height of it ain't it ain't
it ain't it we all
said we all said hey go out you can go
buy a PlayStation game someplace else
and guys went around looking they could
not find anywhere else to buy these
games but only from
Sony that is a
monopoly that's going to get broken up
the practices that you have right now is
coming home to
roost you should have accepted the
deal
this is what happens when you don't
accept the offerings
that you see you were part of a team oh
my Lord we talked to you Jim we had you
at the golf course uhuh I love how this
has full circle to Xbox full circle to
Xbox oh yes this is definitely
definitely who benefits with they gone
we
do Xbox front line we got him oh this is
the front line this is part of the this
is part of the whole this part of the
strategy expose the tactics we keep the
boot on their necks we do not stop we
push and if you can get part of that
lawsuit I want you to go switch your
region and your
PlayStation oh now everybody everybody
need to be suffer like the UK okay yo
I'm going go switch my joy to UK time
right now you trying to get the card in
the mail you trying to get the card in
the mail and said that you was
affected you know add that c in the mail
they trying to send you hey yo there's a
big lwuit going on if you had a
PlayStation king king's gonna open up a
PO Box there yeah yeah he all of a
sudden the UK got suffering I got I got
family in
London I was affected just like the rest
of you so I want y'all all to switch
your uh your region and then you know
it's going to be funny let's say they
win that and king gets paid and then
there's another there's a there's a
class action over here and King's
refiling for that Bessie Bessie no it's
just it's just it's just crazy to see
that all the practices and everything
has come out after documents to hit the
streets and everybody has galvanized and
went to the part where they said this is
not going to happen anymore and um I'm
down for
this I'm down all about the failure I'm
all about this I told you you will be an
app and y'all are helping me every step
of the
way had your thoughts on uh play store
being called out for monopolistic
practices this lawsuit is continuing
they did not throw out the case your
thoughts on this sir you can't what king
said okay what king said that's where he
at with it look I'll jump in um I will
give King this normally K&N news is out
of pocket but the fact that they didn't
throw it out I mean it's a big deal it
is a big deal and it's I don't know if
they're going to win I do I have to
admit though in this episode of doub and
Abby with
kid that it do look a little suspect
that if this is true that like for us we
could go get a code from Amazon Best Buy
y for Nintendo switch digital Xbox games
digital if my UK Lords if let me know if
this is true if you really can't go and
get PlayStation games only from their
store that's that's not a competition
practice that is very monopolistic
that's you're the only store Front in
town I just need confirmation I haven't
done research enough to say definitively
but UK Lords if this is true that is a
monopolistic practice K&N can confirm KN
andn confirm I know KN andn Affiliates
is out there you know what I'm saying
but let's see KNN is the truth you can't
okay no a couple Lords saying you yeah
you can't get them anywhere for PC you
can from games in the UK can or can't
akw because I think you're out there I'm
from the UK Captain chat it's true wow
okay okay interesting and I sympathize
with you and I whole some someone says
K&N has confirmed K&N has confirmed and
I hope you're part of this lawsuit there
so you can get some money there guy okay
all right so this where it is so akw is
disagreeing with y'all he says he can
get digital games PlayStation other than
lock him
up seize him seize him I want I want a
meme on Facebook with the courtroom
thing where King's
pointing doing what you call it lock him
up yeah so look we'll see if it it's
true it is interested it's sto out and
um yeah if it's true then yeah they they
going to get that work uh legally so
we'll see what it is for the queen yo
y'all still I can't
anyway we got a got A5 Super Chat his
boss thanks for the entertainment every
week uh we we try man we we go up here
and we we put on a show every week now I
I do want to say I I let me get a couple
announcement things yes yes yes um just
to let you guys know
again next week and the week after will
be the last episodes for the year the
17th the 24th and the
31st we will be taking a break uh we we
we need to re-energize the badges
because they're getting low yep and uh
we will be back on the January 7th of
January as when be back now me and King
might do some like Fight Night stuff but
that's up in the air we don't know if
we're doing that yet uh for the game
award show too as well well that's
before the last yes true yeah so that is
and another thing you know I don't
really put my personal life or family
out here A whole lot I did unfortunately
have a family member uh that passed away
he was actually murdered but we ain't
going into that that yeah but um I'm
gonna throw the GoFundMe that my family
has going for him in the chat absolutely
you know if you guys got a couple coins
put in it's Thanksgiving you know my
family got to worry about barri thing
like he was you passed away absolutely
terrible he he passed away on
Thanksgiving and oh my God if you guys
got something in there just to help out
you know what's funny is just like I met
him a few times he was a good dude good
good good father good grandfather always
in his grandkids life and got an
altercation with his neighbor and you
know that's why I always say your life
is worth more than arguing with people
yous just you know stay away but you
know if you guys got something I really
appreciate my family they they
struggling right now man they struggling
and during this Christmas stuff they
shouldn't have to worry about that stuff
so if you guys have anything man I would
appreciate it no doubt much love from
the realm you already know and again
like S I mean like adex said we got on
next week and then after that next week
then we probably will start our break
and stuff like that so yeah we got the
super chats caught up anything else we
got going on let's do our outros and
actually no before I do that let's do
the poll question cuz
B will K
MEP with rumors of Xbox having a
presence at the game awards which of
these do you think would have the
biggest impact choices are a hellblade
2's combat shown at the game of WS B
risk it for the biscuit if you hear you
going to like this one gear six reveal a
lot of people think gears might be there
C Indiana Jones SL machine games little
TD little God Howard come outside or D I
don't care Jeff still got to admit that
this Xbox tax is real that's what's
going on it'll be up in there shout out
to G he said your hellblade too is on
there he said if it's not hellblade
they're in trouble nah N I don't want to
see hellblade again I'm sorry I don't I
am tired of seeing hellblade Oh no
please from SP 661 you guys are the main
event every Sunday wife and I enjoy you
guys us us are awesome appreciate it man
love SP 661 everybody enjoy your Sunday
we going to have some fun in the Realms
again condolences and Lord addict your
thoughts to what you want to say to the
people yeah really appreciate coming
through we had uh over a thousand people
like 1100 something like that you
there's a lot of people in there no
there was a lot of people in there which
segment which segment let's break it the
that we had a thousand they was there
for even when I messed up I I messed up
the we did we did lose about a 100 when
you when it was just homeboy from TX
doing this yeah I I was showing a herang
live
stream crazy yeah so you know I
appreciate for coming through you know
it's been a pretty uh hectic day there's
a lot of stuff going on think who you
guys want okay look who you guys want to
send you guys to man we got we got we uh
we got
really no F isn't f is always live later
okay uh I consider you guys to to game
on uh Co what ASA or oh G ASA ASA yeah I
can send you guys to as so I'm G send
you guys to ASA go in there and tell
them IOP raid I want I'm looking I'm
looking no we we look I can send you
guys a weap but there's plenty of people
on weap send them to
ig no unfortunately you know what you
know what you know you want to jump
that's the stream though yesterday right
we that I I
prefer what is what is that procedure
what what what is that procedure when
they when when they when they rip your
brain out that I prefer to have that a
labotomy oh God I will go through a
labotomy before I send anyone to ig I
thought was G to send them over to ig if
they was no but I'm sending you guys
over to Asia I'm not leave yet I'm not
sending you to weapon will because weap
will got a plenty base I'm sending you
to people that actually can
yeah that need the grow like myself like
myself okay like myself anyway l k get a
five find you what you got go on you can
find me at Xbox Frontline news with K&N
lives and so does uh you know uh Kos and
combat talk with the King uh for all the
members that have uh that have joined I
truly appreciate you uh working on
patreon uh the store is coming up we
working on the merch in the background
that stuff should be up uh before the
Christmas holiday um itself uh I just
want to thank um all
4,738 guys that uh follow um subscribe
um we're close to 5,000 woo um it's
absolutely insane but um I got 23 videos
up in a couple of weeks so that means
I'm putting out a video every day uh all
the K&N news that I can't tell
here
the streets I I'll put it up adct has
been a tremendous help yes I'mma tell
you something like I I
don't you don't know how much this man
does understand and what I don't like is
a lot of you guys haven't had him on
your show Facts haven't reached out to
him facts you think like he's
ancillary and he he's not and um where
with my brother can't go I can't go
salute so shout out the Alex I just I
just got to say you know um I just have
to stand with mine I feel and and um
gotta hold the line yeah I love I love
all of you but where my brother can't
walk neither can
I so um I love you I'll miss you guys
but if I check you and I and I check
with him and he he's never been there he
never got the invite don't invite
me love y Des Leary has a tweet um adct
if you're
interested uh yes I fig give some
breaking news what act that breaking he
said it about a couple hours ago I think
I said what I'm going to say about the
Xbox tax at this point I've been an Xbox
fan since the start and that's never
going to change I believe the Xbox brand
is about to have an incredible 2024 and
it feels like it's just the tip of the
iert I've always seen the path to
further success for Xbox I feel like
they have all the pieces set up exactly
right now
and once they hit their stride it will
be undeniable looking forward to
watching it all play out and discussing
it along the way so it looks like a
little pece offering attic little little
pie he's feeling that heat oh damn y not
accepting the treaty he's feeling that
heat he's sitt there he's like oh God
man where's that where's that Twitter oh
my God you know as as a Xbox dude you
already know is the Xbox tax don't do
that and um don't don't do it because
the people that you're standing with is
running around With the Enemy and you
just don't want to be ostracized I
understand that you need to fit in and I
love you I truly do but you no no no
you're only going to be judged on your
stances if you know something is wrong
you got to point it out Peter Parker did
not stop the riber and Uncle Ben
died with great power comes great
responsibility either you're a superhero
or you're a cow
all right no King has spoken all I will
say is or whatever side of the I wasn't
talking about him I just talking about
people in general in general in general
and all all I say is whatever side
you're on just please be respectful no
death threats no talking about people
crazy yeah like let's not do nothing
crazy that's all that's all I say
regardless of God anyway that's try try
to play the game pass yes yes yes yes
yes but anyway that's all I got
everybody enjoy your weekend we up out
of here remember yes remember go in
there and say I op raid yes that
GoFundMe one more time in the chat guys
no doubt I got one more thing it's gonna
be for next week GNA Dave do something
fun that y'all been asking for for me as
far as that we got something cooking
with gravic God no ain't no beef a shout
out hold on shout out to F he said Xbox
tag isn't real is how much as in how
much think of it anyway okay fair enough
fair enough whatever side you want
whatever you y yo cord way you messed up
I saw what you're doing anyway we out of
here enjoy your Sunday peace
[Music]
peace